Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle. Ausgabe Nummer 36, eine weitere Iteration hier bei unserem Versuch, uns der Wissenschaft zu nähern aus zahlreichen Aspekten. Und ja heute ist mal wieder so ein Blick von oben angesagt. Wir wollen uns der Internationalisierung der Forschung ein wenig nähern. Diese findet ja ganz offensichtlich schon seit einiger Zeit ganz intensiv statt und wird in zunehmendem Maße ein Thema und das nicht erst, aber auch jetzt neu, wegen des Brexits, dem drohenden Austritts Großbritanniens aus der Europäischen Union. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner Ulrich Schreiterer, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ulrich du bist beim Wissenschaftszentrum Berlin, WZB, ich glaube unter dieser Abkürzung kennt man das vor allem auch, zuständig, soweit ich das sehe, für Wissenschaftspolitik im Allgemeinen, aber auch so Hochschulentwicklung, Governance, aber auch Internationalisierung der Forschung. Das heißt das ist sozusagen auch schon ein Ding dieser Begriff?
Internationalisierung der Forschung ist seit vielen Jahren ein Ding. Das sieht man zum Beispiel daran, dass es auch spätestens seit Mitte der 2000er Jahre, der ersten Dekade, entsprechende Dokumente gibt. Die Bundesregierung hat beispielsweise 2008 unter Federführung des Forschungsministeriums eine Internationalisierungsstrategie veröffentlicht, die dann seither immer wieder fortgeschrieben worden ist und auch die EU hat im selben Jahr eine, das genaue Dokument weiß ich jetzt nicht, Internationalisation, initiative oder EU going global in research verabschiedet, in der gewissermaßen Ziele, Leitlinien, Leitplanken manifestiert wurden. Und das ist natürlich einerseits ein Treiber, andererseits reflektiert es Entwicklungen, denen man sich auf Seiten der Politik, aber eben auch der einzelnen Institutionen stellen muss.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf die WZB auch selber nochmal eingehen, würde mich natürlich erst mal so ein bisschen auch dein persönlicher Hintergrund interessieren. Wie bist du überhaupt in diese Wissenschaftswelt geraten? Und wie kommt man dann auch auf die Idee, über Forschung zu forschen.
Naja gut, ich bin von der Herkunft her Soziologe und Historiker. Hatte fast mal die Exit gemacht in Richtung alte Geschichte und habe dann aber über verschiedene lebensgeschichtliche Zufälle, wie es eben doch immer sehr viele gibt, dann eine wenn man will Karriere im akademischen Management gemacht, in der Hochschuladministration. Ich war Referent eines Rektors in der Universität Bielefeld und war dann später im Wissenschaftsrat in verschiedenen Funktionen tätig am zentralen Beratungsorgan des Bundes und der Länder, mit der einer wissenschaftlichen Kommission in Fragen der Wissenschafts- und Forschungspolitik in Deutschland. Habe dann einige in Gütersloh bei einer Ausgründung der Bertelsmann-Stiftung, nämlich dem Zentrum für Hochschulentwicklung gearbeitet. Und war dann zwischen 2003 und 2008 an der Yale University als sogenannter Senior Research Scholar für International High Education.
Und bin seither, also seit Mitte 2008 am Wissenschaftszentrum Berlin. Das von dem deutschen Namen her eigentlich nicht so präzise ist wie der englische Begriff. Das heißt nämlich Berlin Social Science Center und da rücken sozusagen die Sozialwissenschaften in den Mittelpunkt. Und auf die Forschung bin ich, wenn man so will, durch meine berufspraktische Tätigkeit gekommen, von der ich mich dann ein Stück weit, wenn man so will, auch entfernen wollte und mal da drauf gucken und das theoretisch reflektieren, was ich da in verschiedenen Funktionen am Anfang meiner Berufstätigkeit vor allen Dingen gemacht habe.
Womit setzt sich denn jetzt so das WZB so insgesamt auseinander?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Es hat ein Leitbild oder eine Leitfloskel, kann man fast sagen, die nennt sich die problemorientierte Grundlagenforschung im Bereich von Sozialwissenschaften. Und es ist ein relativ großer Laden und umfasst verschiedene Disziplinen. Wir haben also etwa 150 Wissenschaftler dort in verschiedenen Funktionen und Stand in ihrer Karriere am arbeiten. Und es sind Soziologen, die sich mit Fragen wie sozialer Ungleichheit, Berufseinmündungen, Entwicklung der Lebensphasen beschäftigen. Es sind aber eben auch Ökonomen, die machen Verhaltensökonomie, Spieltheorie. Es sind Politikwissenschaftler, die sich mit Fragen der transnationalen Governance und supranationaler Regime beschäftigen. Mit Demokratietheorie beschäftigen.
Es gibt Rechtswissenschaftler, die sich auch mit Global Governance und dem was sozusagen am globalen Rechtssystem da ist beschäftigen. Es gibt sehr sehr viele. Es gibt sieben Abteilungen. Es gibt jede Menge an kleineren, wenn man so will, Projektgruppen. Und die Fülle der Themen, Probleme, Arbeiten ist sehr groß.
Und dieser Bereich, den du da sozusagen bekleidest, gab es den schon immer oder ist das eher so etwas, was jüngst dazu gekommen ist?
Es gibt seit einigen Jahren, allerdings bin ich jetzt da nicht direkt Mitglied in diesem Bereich, eine Abteilung, bzw. nicht eine Abteilung, eine Projektgruppe, das ist ein kleineres Format von Wissenschaftspolitik, Forschungsgruppe Wissenschaftspolitik. Und da wird vor allen Dingen eben auch über Forschung nachgedacht und erforscht, wie Wissenschaftler arbeiten, die Motivation von Wissenschaftlern, Karriereverläufe von Wissenschaftlern, Aspirationen, Formen der Kooperation von Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft. Eine Vielzahl von Arbeiten in diesem Bereich. Das ist sozusagen, wenn man so will, thematisch der Ort in diesem Zentrum, in dem das im Mittelpunkt steht. Aber es gibt darüber hinaus eben doch eine ganze Reihe von Leuten auch in dem Bereich der internationalen Politikwissenschaft, die sich mit solchen Fragen am Rande eher beschäftigen. Und ich bin, in dem wie ich das mache, von der internationalen Perspektive gewissermaßen da ein Unikat.
Wer ist so die … wie soll ich das formulieren … also wer hört auf das BZB oder mit wem steht man so in Kommunikation? An wen sind diese Forschungsergebnisse gerichtet? Das ist ja jetzt nicht nur so eine reine, ja wir forschen jetzt mal soziologisch über Wissenschaft und schreiben unsere Paper, sondern es ist ja ein Prozess, der sehr viel mehr auch in den Systemen integriert ist, sich sehr viel mehr anlehnt aus meiner Perspektive oder ist das falsch?
Naja es kommt in der Tat sehr auf das Gebiet und auf das jeweilige Fach an bzw. auch die Personen, wie dann die Communitys oder man könnte auch sagen, Abnehmer der Stakeholders da organisiert sind. Und wenn man jetzt guckt, wenn man beispielsweise Arbeiten macht über Bildungsverläufe und die Bildungschancen von Kindern, und ob dann Jungen diskriminiert werden in der Schule oder was denn getan werden kann gegen Bildungsarmut und, wenn man so will, Bildungsgerechtigkeit zu verbessern, dann ist das eine andere Klientel, die darauf hört und da hat man eine andere Community, in der man dann mit diesen Ergebnissen auch wahrgenommen wird und die man beeinflusst, als wenn man zum Beispiel etwas macht über theoretische Probleme würde ich mal eher sagen der ökonomischen Wahltheorie, also des behavioural economics devices. Und in meinem Fall ist es eher so, dass es eine internationale Community gibt von Wissenschaftsforschern, aber auch vor allen Dingen jetzt so Wissenschaftspolitikern, die sich beobachten.
Und die sich auf Konferenzen treffen und die auch in die, wenn man so will, staatlichen Akteure hineingehen, also Ministerien oder Forschungsfördererorganisationen, die ihrerseits wiederum sehr international vernetzt sind. Und beispielsweise dann eben auch in Form in Arenen wie der EU oder in Arenen wie der OECD oder in internationalen Wissenschaftsorganisationen ihren, wenn man so will, Gegenpart haben. Also ich beispielsweise bin beteiligt an einem von der EU finanzierten unter Horizon 2020 finanzierten großen Verbundprojekt, in dem es unter Science Diplomacy geht, also Wissenschaftsdiplomatie, um die, wenn man so will, auch im Kern die Internationalisierung der Wissenschaft, wie Wissenschaft zum einen mit Hilfe der Außenpolitik oder was die Außenpolitik tun kann, um die Wissenschaft  zu internationalisieren und was möglicherweise Wissenschaft international beitragen kann zur Konfliktlösung.
Oder um Anbahnung von Kooperationen zu erreichen. Und da ist im zentralen Interesse der EU. Die Kommission hat, wenn man so will, da eine Art von Beratungsauftrag ausgeschrieben oder einen Wunsch, sich darüber schlau zu machen, was dann auch möglicherweise für sie als Kommission, als Handlungsfeld oder Politikfeld daraus erwachsen kann.
Also so richtig so suprainternational. Also sozusagen mit allen, die auch international denken, nochmal international vernetzt?
Genau. Macht dann Ping Pong.
Nicht schlecht. An der Stelle kurze Erwähnung, das Thema Horizon 2020 oder Horizont 2020 hatten wir hier auch schonmal im Gespräch bei Forschergeist in der Ausgabe 13. Wer das vielleicht noch nicht gehört hat, das ist dann ein ganz dedizierter Exkurs zu diesem Forschungsprogramm der EU. Das soll hier jetzt nur am Rande ein Thema sein, spielt aber natürlich gerade jetzt in Europa eine sehr große Rolle. Kommen wir sicherlich auch nochmal drauf, wenn wir uns den Brexit nochmal genauer anschauen. Wenn man jetzt zurückblickt in die Geschichte, dann war ja mal Forschung doch eine, wie so viele wirtschaftliche Aktivitäten natürlich auch, eine sehr nationale Angelegenheit, getrennt durch Sprache, durch eine andere Wissenschaftsgeschichte. Es waren ja auch nicht so viele Länder ursprünglich wirklich an so einem wissenschaftlichen Zug beteiligt.
Und überhaupt ist ja auch, das hatten wir ja hier auch in zahlreichen Rückblicken auf die Wissenschaftsgeschichte, ist ja sozusagen auch diese Vorstellung, dass Wissenschaft ein ganz eigenes Gebiet und ein ganz eigener Entwicklungsbereich ist oder dass man überhaupt auch hauptamtlich Wissenschaftler sein kann und das nicht nur so als Abfallprodukt tut. Im Prinzip ja auch erst so seit 100 Jahren erst so nicht auf dem Tisch. Wann hat sich denn diese Internationalisierung, die sich ja heute gar nicht mehr abstreiten lässt, auf den Weg gemacht? Wann fing denn dieses internationale Geflecht auch an, eins zu werden?
Also ein bisschen ist das ein Paradox. Weil die Forschung, ob das in Hochschulen oder da wo es so etwas gibt, außer den universitären Forschungseinrichtungen als Ort, in dem Forschung betrieben wird, betrifft, ist überwiegende nationalstaatlich organisiert, finanziert und war oft meistens, jedenfalls im Ursprung ist es bis heute ein nationales Unternehmen. Zugleich war Forschung, also insbesondere die naturwissenschaftliche Forschung, in den Leitdisziplinen Physik, aber dann eben auch in Chemie und weniger dann gerade Biologie, immer von ihrem Selbstverständnis her weniger international als universal. Das heißt es gab eine deutsche Physik, hat es mal gegeben mit bekanntem Ende, sondern es gibt eine Physik, die überall auf der Welt gleich ist. Die Wissenschaftlergemeinschaft derer, die dann Physik machten, ob das Hochenergiephysiker oder Festkörperphysiker ist, ist international, da spielt es keine Rolle, ob ich aus Pakistan, aus Japan, aus Lippe oder aus Schleswig-Holstein komme.
Die spricht dann eben auch leider vielleicht oder auch nicht eine gemeinsame Sprache neben deren Form in Englisch. Also dieses war immer da, wenn man so will, dieses doppelte. Es ist eine nationale Aufgabe, ein nationales auch Prestigeobjekt, Wissenschaft zu betreiben, Forschung zu finanzieren, Forschungsergebnisse zu haben, Forschungseinrichtungen, derer sich ein Land rühmen kann und zugleich war es eben die internationale Community. Und die Internationalisierung der Forschung jedenfalls manifestiert in Forschungskooperationen, die über die Institutsländergrenzen hinausgehen, wo Leute aus ganz unterschiedlichen Kontexten und Ländern zusammen arbeiten und dann auch gemeinsam publizieren, hat etwa seit den 1980er Jahren begonnen. Und seither einen extrem hohen Aufschwung erlebt. Also wenn man sich die Zahlen der internationalen Partnerschaften, die also in Forschungspraktik da sind, anschaut, dann sind das ungefähr nach Schätzungen 35% mittlerweile, die international fachübergreifend gemacht werden.
Und vor allen Dingen kann man das ja sozusagen jetzt manifestieren oder ausdrücken in den Kopublikationen. Da waren es 1990 bis 2000 ein Anwuchs um 100% auf damals 15% aller Publikationen, die internationale Koautoren hatten. Heute 2012, also dann 10 Jahre später, 12 Jahre später, sind es 25%, fast nochmal verdoppelt. Das heißt innerhalb von 20 Jahren verdreifacht. Und das ist schon ganz enorm. Hat damit zu tun, dass – und das kann man durch vielerlei Nachmessungen belegen – dass Publikationen und ich rede jetzt hier über Zeitschriftenaufsätze in den wissenschaftlichen Journals, die internationale Koautorenschaften aufweisen, sehr viel häufiger zitiert werden als solche, die nur nationale Autorenschaften aufhaben.
Und die Zitationen einer Publikation, einer wissenschaftlichen Publikation, sind, wenn man so will, die Währung, in der der Wert dieser Arbeit bemessen wird, zu weiten Teilen. Also insofern ist es für Wissenschaftler auch aus diesem Grunde attraktiv, solche Koproduktionen einzugehen.
Aber warum ist das so? Also warum werden solche Papers öfter zitiert, wenn sie international entstanden sind? Weil da einfach mehr Nähe zu den Personen ist, die da noch beteiligt sind?
Genau, also das wäre sozusagen die einfachste Vermutung. Dass da jede dieser Personen, die da beteiligt sind, natürlich ihre eigene Community hat und dann auch über welche Wege immer diese Publikation streut, verbreitet, darauf aufmerksam macht, so dass dann wenn dann mehrere aus mehreren Ländern beteiligt sind, dann prima vista schon mal eine größere Bandbreite hat.
Also hat dieses meritokratische Element, das sich dann sozusagen auch über die Grenzen hinweg ausbreitet?
Networking nennt man das. Da hat jeder sein Netz und der bringt das dann eben da unter. Das ist einfach eine größere Community, in der das dann Widerhall findet oder überhaupt aufgenommen werden kann. Ein anderer Aspekt, warum das so ist, mag damit zu tun haben, dass ja natürlich Wissenschaftler heute mehr denn je unter verschiedenen Parametern unter extremem Leistungsdruck stehen. Das heißt sie müssen sich bewehren. In vielen Ländern wird mittlerweile das Gehalt, die Beförderungschancen sowieso oder die Chancen, eine feste Anstellung zu bekommen in der Wissenschaft ganz angefangen, danach bemessen, was ich produziere und wie ich weiter produziere. Das hießt ich habe dann, wenn man so will, meine Leistungsbilanz, die sich eben auch in dem Forschungsoutput niederschlägt und jeder versucht, jeder Wissenschaftler versucht, seine Reputation zu steigern, seine Anerkennung in der Community, aber eben auch diese, wenn man so will, Sternchen auf der Litze.
Die dann möglicherweise in Positionen in monetären Vergütungen und so weiter sich niederschlagen. Das heißt er versucht oder sie versucht, in diesem Spiel mitzumachen. Und wenn man eben weiß, dass internationale Geschichten eine höhere Sichtbarkeit, eine höhere Anerkennung haben, dann ist es, wenn man so will, ökonomisch strategisch rational, auf diese Sache zu setzen.
Also auf jeden Fall ist es ein Fakt, die Internationalisierung der Forschung findet statt. Auch wenn sie nach wie vor national getrieben ist, auch von starken nationalen Interessen getrieben ist, weil die Wissenschaft ja schon dann auch eigentlich immer als Standortvorteil gesehen wird.
Klar, das ist auch eine interessante Geschichte. Wir haben wie gesagt seit jeher gerade in den Naturwissenschaften die Internationalisierung oder die Universalität dieser Disziplin und der Wissenschaftlergemeinschaft. Der sogenannten Scientific Community. Die keine Grenzen, keine Religionen, keine Geschlechter, wenn Frauen überhaupt vorkamen, kannte. Aber eben weil Wissenschaft national organisiert und finanziert ist, und seit ungefähr, ich würde mal sagen, 25-20 Jahren natürlich auch die Rede immer stärker ist von internationaler Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und von im globalen Wettbewerb zu bestehen, der Standort Deutschland und was immer die Äquivalenz für solche Ausdrücke im Japanischen oder im Finnischen sein mögen, spielt für die Wissenschaftspolitik, aber auch für die Wissenschaftspraxis eine immer größere Rolle.
Es geht um Competetiveness, um Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, um Sicherung von Chancen und von Spitzenforschung, Sichtbarkeit und da sind natürlich solche internationalen Publikationen, international Forschungskooperationen, wenn man so will, ein Ort, an dem sich das austrägt, an dem das eingefangen wird. Oder man kann auch sagen, der Kriegsschauplatz. Also beispielsweise im amerikanischen Englisch ist seit ungefähr 15 Jahren ein Begriff gebräuchlich, der politically nicht korrekt ist, aber wie gesagt sich sehr eingenistet hat, nämlich the War on Talents. Es gab den WOT, den War on Terror von George W. Bush, aber es gibt eben in der Wissenschaftlergemeinschaft den War on Talents, das heißt dass die amerikanischen Hochschulen die besten, brightest, smartest Studenten weltweit zu rekrutieren versuchen, jedenfalls von den PGDlern dann hinterher.
Und es gibt eben auch diesen War on Talents, insofern man die besten Köpfe, die besten Wissenschaftlerköpfe versucht in die jeweiligen Länder hinein zu holen, in die jeweiligen Systeme hinein zu holen.
Der War of was? Auf die Intelligenz oder?
Ja Talent. Talente. Die wissenschaftlichen Talente. Die Köpfe. Also Wissenschaft geht durch Köpfe, es ist nicht nur Ressourcen. Ich kann viele Ressourcen reinstellen, da passiert nichts, wenn ich nicht die richtige Software oder die richtig Peopleware habe.
Also so Headhunting im eigentlichen Sinne
Headhunting ist eine der, also für amerikanische Universitäten der Spitzenliga, schon seit langem ein großes Feld, aber wird eben auch in internationalen Bereichen immer wichtiger mit wer weiß was für unkeuschen Angeboten, die abzuwerben die Menschen, also die sich irgendwie identifiziert haben als möglicherweise zum Beispiel Nobelpreisträger. Das sieht man ja überall und allerorten. Und beispielsweise hier, um ein nachfliegendes Beispiel zu nehmen, deutsche Universitäten und aus Forschungseinrichtungen werden auch immer internationaler. Und nicht nur, weil das irgendwie sozusagen multikulti, nett und schön ist, sondern weil man da eben solche Talente haben will. Also 10% der Wissenschaftler an deutschen Universitäten sind pi mal Daumen nicht deutschnational, vielleicht im Pass oder jedenfalls haben einen Migrationshintergrund gesehen, nicht in Deutschland geboren.
Und bei zum Beispiel der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft ist das, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche, unter den Direktoren und vor allen den Nachwuchsgruppenleuten ist das jetzt also auch schon bald mehr als ein Drittel, wenn nicht gar 40% der Menschen, die dort nicht aus Deutschland kommen und vielleicht noch nicht mal deutsch sprechen.
Stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wenn so ein Krieg angebrochen ist, die Talente zu holen, was macht ein Standort jetzt auch für internationale Forscher dann unterm Strich auch wirklich lebenswert und damit attraktiv? Was sind denn so die Argumente der Headhunter? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, Reputation der Forschungseinrichtung spielt auf jeden Fall eine Rolle, aber ist sicherlich auch nicht das einzige Element in dieser Gleichung?
Nein. Also es sind im Grunde genommen zwei Sachen, auf die es vor allen Dingen ankommt. Erstens, wenn man so will, die Peers, das heißt ich komme in eine Gruppe rein, in eine Umgebung, in der es schon andere sehr gute Leute gibt und muss mich jetzt also nicht als, wenn man so will, Leuchtturm unter lauter ungetauften dann da behauten. Und also dass es auch für mich attraktiv sein kann. Also sozusagen die gegenseitige Anziehungskraft derer, die da zusammen gebracht werden. Es ist natürlich schwierig. Ob das dann funktioniert ist immer noch eine andere Geschichte. Also das ist das eine und das andere ist natürlich die Ausstattung des jeweiligen Arbeitsbereiches, die je nach Disziplin unterschiedlich wichtig und unterschiedlich teuer sein kann. Also ein theoretischer Physiker oder auch gar reiner Mathematiker braucht da vielleicht nicht sehr viel. Aber wenn ich jetzt experimentell arbeitender, ich weiß jetzt nicht was, …
Partikel beschleunigen.
Ja Partikel beschleunigen, ja gut das sind ja also oft dann auch große Forschungszentren, an denen ganz viele beteiligt sind, aber wenn ich das jetzt so vor Ort machen muss als Polymerchemiker oder ich weiß nicht, was es da alles gibt an Bereichen, die sehr apparateintensiv und teuer sind, und ich viele viele Menschen brauche, die diese Versuche laufen.[00:23:53-1 @timpritlove>Teure Materialen.
Teure Materialien, dann ist das was anderes. Und natürlich ist es auch, das ist dann aber eher ein dritter Punkt, der nicht ganz so zentral ist, aber nicht vernachlässigt werden dürfte, eine Frage des Gehaltes, das man diesen Menschen anbieten kann. Das war übrigens einer der Gründe, warum vor ungefähr 12 Jahren in Deutschland, 15 Jahren, die Vergütung für Professoren verändert worden ist. Und man hat dann auch gesagt, wir müssen in der Lage sein, international wettbewerbsfähige Konditionen in den Gehältern bieten zu können.
Also Geld, kann man mal festhalten, ist auf jeden Fall ein Faktor, wenn man gut verdient und wenn man vor allem eine Menge Kohle bereit gestellt bekommt, um einfach sich den ganzen Kram zusammen zu shoppen, den man so braucht, gar keine Frage.
Genau.
Aber das ist ja sicherlich auch nicht das einzige?
Nein ich sagte ja, das wichtigste ist wahrscheinlich die Umgebung. Die intellektuelle…
Was schon da ist?
Was da ist oder was ich möglicherweise, es gibt ja dann…
Oder was für Freiräume man zugestanden bekommt…
Genau, man baut dann beispielsweise ein neues Institut auf und holt dann sich die Leute rein. Ein Beispiel zu geben, Korea hat seit 2013 einen interessanten Versuch gemacht in genau diesem Spiel da mitzuspielen. Die haben nämlich ein Land – wir kennen alle Samsung, auch ohne S3 und Hyundai diese Autos und ich weiß nicht, - also das von diesen Großindustrien geprägt war, die auch die Forschungspolitik bestimmten und die sehr sehr sehr anwendungsorientiert gewesen ist. Die waren immer sozusagen die schnellsten im Followup innovieren. Haben extrem hohen Ausgabenanteil für Forschung und Innovation. Das ist also am Anteil des Bruttosozialproduktes liegt Korea an der Spitze weltweit, was die ausgeben. Und die hatten den Eindruck, sie kommen an eine, wie sie das nannten, glass ceiling. Sie konnten an einem bestimmten Punkt nicht mehr, sie konnten Geld ausgeben was sie wollten, aber sie kommen nicht weiter, sie kriegen keine wirkliche Durchbruchinnovation, wie das heißt.
Und dann haben die sich gedacht, okay wir versuchen es auf eine andere Art und Weise, nämlich wir versuchen Spitzenforschung einzukaufen und zu kreieren. Sie haben ein neues Institut for Basic Science gegründet, in dem die Menschen, die dort berufen sind, es sollen insgesamt 50 oder 60 solcher Abteilungen oder Gruppen geben, wenn man so will, kleine Institute unter dem Dach, die sollen die größtmögliche Freiheit bekommen, die größtmöglichen Ressourcen, derer sie bedürfen, um ihre Arbeiten zu machen. Und man lässt die fünf Jahre lang, was für Korea völlig ungewöhnlich ist, einfach mal machen und guckt dann, was kommt da raus? Und das kostet das Land natürlich sehr viel, das sind einige Milliarden, die dafür ausgeben werden, aber es ist, wenn man so will, der Versuch, eine in anderen Ländern erfolgreiche …
Was neues oder ist das etwas, was schon vor einer Weile begonnen hat?
Das hat 2013 angefangen. Die ersten Institute haben 2015 ihre Arbeit aufgenommen. Also das ist noch verdammt neu. Man kann nicht sagen, ob das einen Erfolg hat. Aber es zeigt, wenn man so will, wie interessant oder wie schlagend solche internationalen Beispiele sind. Jeder guckt auf den anderen und alle gucken einander ab, was man denn machen könnte, um eigentlich solche wissenschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit zu steigern. In der Hoffnungen Amit auch Innovation zu generieren. Und natürlich ist wissenschaftliche Leistung gleich Spitzenforschung immer mit Talenten verbunden, mit Leuten, die man dafür braucht. Und dann guckt man eben, wie kriege ich die möglicherweise sozusagen da an einen Ort? Was brauche ich da, um einenn entsprechenden, wenn man so will, einen solchen Inkubator dann da hin zu bekommen.
Ist auch eine interessante Abkehr von dem alten Modus, den man ja auch in Japan stark gesehen hat, China natürlich auch. Wir kopieren jetzt erst mal sozusagen das was uns der Westen jetzt schon seit Jahrzehnten vorexerziert hat, das heißt wir verstehen überhaupt erst mal die Technologien, wir kopieren die Fertigungsmethoden, optimieren sie dann sozusagen mit einer vielleicht etwas anderen Brille auf Arbeitsprozesse und Workflows und damit ist ja schon eine enorme wirtschaftliche Entwicklung und auch gesellschaftliche Entwicklung losgetreten worden, die dann aber sozusagen genau an diese Glaswand stößt, wo man halt sagt, okay um jetzt aber auch überholen zu können und nicht nur aufholen zu können und auch voranschreiten zu können, muss man im Prinzip auch etwas anderes kopieren, nämlich dass man gar nicht mehr kopiert, dass man im Prinzip selber anfängt, vorne loszulaufen. Und ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass das nicht nur Asien erfasst hat, sondern auch zum Beispiel stark den arabischen Raum.
Ja.
Dubai ist da ein Beispiel, Abu Dhabi sicherlich noch andere.
Saudi Arabien, da gibt es diese KAIST, King Abdul Institute of Science of Technology. Das ist eine mit Ressourcen obenhin vollgestopfte Universität, die sehr viele internationale Wissenschaftler, oft dann auch schon sehr erfahrene und gut ausgewiesene, mit horrenden Gehältern für zum Zeit nur ein Teil der Zeit einkauft, dass sie dann drei Monate dort sind, aber dann möglicherweise auch von ihnen verlangt, dass sie dann ihre Publikationen, das ist immer eine Frage der Zurechnung, als Mitglieder dieser KAIST dann da ausflaggen, um damit dann sozusagen diese Institution in die Weltspitze hochzuschießen.
Geld haben die ja, gar keine Frage.
Geld haben die ohne Ende.
Sie sind auch auf eine interessante Art und Weise kompromissbereit. Also bei Saudi Arabien habe ich mir das jetzt noch gar nicht so angeschaut. Dubai ist ja an sich auch ein Ort, der sich ja in den letzten Jahrzehnten trotz natürlich stark konservativ religiös verwurzelter Herkunft doch schon so Inseln der internationalen Öffnung geschaffen hat, dass man gesagt hat, ja ihr könnt ja mal alle hierher kommen, das gilt jetzt nicht nur für die Wissenschaft, sondern generell.
Nö Kunst.
Für den Handel. Und dabei ja im Prinzip auch megainternationale Orte geschaffen haben. Also Dubai ist ohnehin ja bekannt für seine Übertreibungen, aber es ist ja erstaunlich, wie breit gestreut die Welt dort vertreten ist auf viele Arten und Weisen. Für Saudi Arabien könnte ich mir vorstellen ist das ein bisschen schwieriger.
Es ist schwieriger, aber es gibt natürlich da ein ähnliches Problem wie in Dubai und in den ganzen Emiraten, nämlich die Aussicht, was machen wir denn, wenn diese Öl- oder Gasressourcen verbraucht sind oder möglicherweise auch eine andere Form von Wirtschaft da ist, dass man nicht mehr so von diesen fossilen Brennstoffen abhängig wird. Dass jedenfalls das Zeug nicht mehr zu den bisherigen Preisen, die ja nun das Staatsbudget und die ganze Wirtschaft füttern, verkauft werden kann. Und sozusagen für diese post oil oder post carbon Zeiten haben die nun in mehr oder minder großen Anstrengungen oder Erfolg, weniger großem Erfolg, versucht, irgdwas aufzubauen. Also Fertigungsindustrien, Wirtschaftszweige. Meistens werden die durch Fremdarbeiter bespielt und gespeist. Aber eben auch Wissenschaft. Nach dem Motto, wir wollen und das zeigt wie prägekräftig diese ganzen, wenn man so will, internationalen Skripte sind, wir wollen ein Teil dieser Wissensgesellschaft werden.
Und dafür müssen wir dann, wenn man so will, indigene Ressourcen haben oder indigene Kräfte. Und die kriegen wir nicht aus uns heraus, sondern wir müssen die, wenn man so will, implantieren. Und in der Hoffnung, dass es dann irgendwo dann etwas abwirft für uns auf die mittlere Sicht. Ob das funktioniert keine Ahnung, aber das ist jedenfalls der Kalkül.
Ja gut, das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen, funktioniert das? Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht ein ganz neuer Trend. Es gibt ja, weiß nicht, seit 10 Jahren läuft das auf jeden Fall schon relativ breit an, um nochmal auch dieses Beispiel von Abu Dhabi und Dubai zu kommen, dort haben sich ja auch … also es ist ja nicht nur so, dass dort Forschungszentren oder das ist glaube ich gar nicht mal so, dass dort Forschungszentren selbst jetzt vom Staat gegründet worden sind, sondern im Prinzip hat man international agierende Hochschulen eingeladen, dort eigene Ableger zu machen. Es gibt dort zahlreiche …
Steuerfrei, das ist der große Punkt. Steuerfrei, die bezahlen keine Taxes. Sie kriegen das Land gestellt in einer Freihandelszone. Man hat dann sozusagen den freien Markt der Anbieter. Also sie werden sozusagen durch Steuerfreiheit und Energiekosten spielen ja eh keine Rolle und durch das freie Land werden die subventioniert. Und damit hofft man irgendwie einerseits natürlich internationale Sichtbarkeit zu haben, also was da an Hochschulen alles existiert in den Vereinigten arabischen Emiraten, das ist unglaublich. Aber eben auch möglicherweise für das Land selber etwas hervorzubringen. Wobei das große Problem, wenn ich das recht sehe, ich habe das jetzt nicht im Detail verfolgt, darin besteht, dass möglicherweise ihre eigenen Länder, ihre eigenen Leute gar nicht erreicht werden. Da gehen zwar interessanterweise viele Frauen hin aus diesen jeweiligen Gegenden, aus Saudi Arabien oder aus den Emiraten.
Aber die Männer, ob das im Oman ist oder in Abu Dhabi, die machen sich eher irgendwas anderes. Dann weil sie auch bisher jedenfalls überhaupt keinerlei Anreize haben, da hinzugehen. Warum sollen sie sich da, Entschuldigung, den Hintern aufreißen, irgendwas anstrengen, wenn sie denn gewissermaßen schon eine lebenslange Beschäftigung und zwar mehr als auskömmlich garantiert haben. Als ich weiß es nicht, Palastwächter oder so? Also das ist eine ganz interessante Geschichte.
Spezifisches Problem der arabischen Staaten, der Halbinsel. Wenn man da nur einmal übers Wasser schaut, in Iran ist es ja dann ganz anders.
Da gibt es andere kulturelle Traditionen.
Gibt es andere Traditionen ganz klar, aber auch dort, so wie ich das verstehe, nutzen eben viele Frauen die Möglichkeit über die Wissenschaft sich dort Freiheiten zu erarbeiten, die halt über andere Kanäle so nicht ohne weiteres machbar wären. Ich wollte aber nochmal kurz bei dem Aspekt dieser Hochschulen dort bleiben. Weil im Prinzip ist das ja dann auch … also ich nehme das so ein bisschen wahr als so ein zweiter Schritt. Also wir hatten ja schon gesprochen, die Entwicklung der Internationalisierung, die sich einfach über die Vernetzung, die Verflechtung der wissenschaftlichen Tätigkeit als solcher und der zunehmenden Ausrichtung der nationalen Förderung auf Anwerbung internationaler Wissenschaftler konzentriert hat, dieses Modell aber auch wirklich Ableger von Hochschulen international zu machen, ist ja im Prinzip was ganz neues, wahrscheinlich auch was typisch amerikanisches. Die sozusagen diese Expansionsgedanken schneller haben als andere, weil die Wirtschaft auch schon immer ähnlich aufgebaut war.
Ist das jetzt ein Trend, wenn wir irgendwie eine Humboldt-Universität in Südamerika sehen? Was zeichnet sich da ab oder ist das noch so ein Versuch, wo keiner so genau weiß, wie das so ausgehen wird?
Also das sind ja Gründerzeiten, Gründerjahre, und die sind bekanntlich also nicht immer gut geendet, da gab es auch viele Crashs. Und mit Fontane zu reden ist das ein weites Feld. Also das Ganze hat angefangen in den frühen 90er Jahren, und zwar interessanterweise nicht durch die Amerikaner, sondern vor allen Dingen durch die Briten und durch die Australier. Das hat etwas damit zu tun, dass in den 80er Jahren unter der konservativen Regierung von Maggie Thatcher die Hochschulen massiv auf Schmalkost gesetzt wurden. Die Budgets sind dort gekürzt worden und ganz ähnlich auch in Australien. Und man hat ihnen gleichzeitig aber die Möglichkeit gegeben für Overseas Students. Also die nicht aus dem europäischen Raum kamen, EU-Mitgliedern kamen, sondern irgendwoher, keine Ahnung. Gebühren zu nehmen, die kostendeckend oder sogar darüber hinaus, was immer der Markt hergibt, sind. Und diese Gebühren behalten zu können.
Also da hat man, wenn man so will, ein ökonomisches Moment eingebaut in die Organisation der Universitäten. Und das hat sich dann, wenn man so will, verselbständigt. Die ersten Universitäten, die das dann genutzt haben, um auch zum Beispiel ihre Kurse als, wenn man will, Bachelor oder Master's Degree von der Universität of keine Ahnung Notre Dame, in Indien, in Israel, in Libanon, in Südafrika zu verkaufen, das waren richtige Franchise Unternehmen waren die Briten und die Australier ähnlich. Und der nächste Schritt war dann, nach diesem Franchising von Kursen, Kurs Packages Personal zu leasen, wenn man will. Die dann dahin gingen und vor Ort unterrichtet haben. Und der nächste Schritt war dann, Ausgründung des Unternehmens. Die erste Universität, die das gemacht hat, war die University of Nottingham. Die haben in Malaysia Mitte der 90er Jahre einen Branch Campus aufgebaut.
Und dann ging das sozusagen von dort aus, die Australier mit Monarch haben auch ganz viele in Südafrika und ich weiß nicht was, Monarch-Centers weltweit gebaut, um Ressourcen zu kriegen einerseits, von den Gebühren der dort landenden Studierenden. Aber auch um international, wenn man so will, sichtbar zu werden und ihrerseits dann wieder in dem jeweiligen Land attraktiver zu werden für die Studierenden dort. Und die anderen sind erst spät aufgesprungen auf den Zug. In Deutschland gibt es das seit auch ungefähr Ende der 90er Jahre mit Hilfe des deutschen akademischen Auslandsdienstes, Bundesregierung, Außenministerien wurden dann, wenn man so will, die Internationalisierung der … also Partnerschaften und auch Ausgründenden ermöglicht. Also zum Beispiel die deutsch-türkische Universität ist jetzt ein besonderer Fall, aber in Jordanien, eine unter deutscher Leitung stehende Hochschuleinrichtung, Fachhochschuleinrichtung in German Egyptian University in Kairo.
Es gibt unter der, wenn man so will, Federführung der RWTH seit vielen Jahren, Jahrzehnten solche entsprechenden Geschichten in Singapur. Also da waren viele unterwegs und die Amerikaner waren die relativ späten, die da rein kamen. Und zwar aus dem ganz einfach Grund, weil sie ihren Markenkern, ihr Brand nicht jetzt sozusagen auf dem Markt …
Verbessern wollen.
… also da Discounter werden wollten. Und sie haben angefangen, also die erste war glaube ich meines Wissens die Harvard Businessschool, die ja nun wirklich ein ganz eigener Bereich ist, mit Harvard Science und Arts nicht sehr viel zu tun hatte, die dann irgendwo in Singapur auch eine Art Fortbildungseinrichtung für NBAs dann gemacht hat. Aber jetzt eben Dubai und Singapur oder Shanghai sind andere Dinge. NYU, die New York University war da sehr aktiv. Andere kommen dann auch in die Richtung.
Das hießt dieser Trend ist im Prinzip schon länger abzulesen, aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, war ursprünglich eigentlich mehr so aus Not oder …
Wirtschaftlich.
… Geld, Wirtschaftlichkeitsaspekten so und man hat quasi ja auch so eine Marke aufgebaut und dann eben teilweise mit diesen in der Ferne durchgeführten Kursen oder aus der Ferne durchgeführten Kursen so Geld verdient. Aber da stand ja jetzt dieser eigentliche Gedanke, über den wir jetzt ursprünglich gesprochen hatten, Internationalisierung der Forschung und das Gewinnen neuer Forscher so noch nicht unbedingt im Mittelpunkt.
Nein.
Aber das ist jetzt das Thema?
Das ist, wenn man so will, zwei parallel laufende Schienen. Und die andere Geschichte der internationalen Sichtbarkeit von Hochschulen oder Hochschulangeboten, Standorten das ist ein anderer Diskurs. Der hat was mit diesen internationalen Rankings zu tun. Der hat was auch damit zu tun, dass viele Universitäten jetzt sozusagen Branding-crazy sind, dass sie also ihre Marke international sichtbar platzieren wollen und dafür natürlich auch jenseits von Aachen, jenseits von München, Auftritte irgendwo brauchen, wo die Musik spielt. Um dann Studierende zu attrahieren, die dann nach Aachen oder nach München kommen, also ich meine Oxford und Cambridge haben das nicht nötig. Aber wo dann auch auf längere Sicht möglicherweise ein ökonomischer und prestigereturn für die jeweilige Einrichtung, die das dann macht sich abzeichnen könnte.
Jetzt nur schön das Logo überall draufkleben, das wird ja sicherlich nicht reichen. Lässt sich denn in diesem Zuge der Internationalisierung und der Etablierung einer internationalen Marke auch erkennen, um welche Lernmodelle hier postuliert werden? Also letztlich ist es ja für die Wissenschaftler nicht nur interessant, ach ich geh mal irgendwohin das kennt man und dann habe ich einen Zettel, der irgendwie mehr wert ist, weil Stanford haben schon mal alle gelesen? Sondern man ist ja sozusagen auch an dem eigentlichen wissenschaftlichen Prozess interessiert. Man will ja dann sich auch in etwas hineinbewegen, was funktional dann auch die eigene Arbeit wirklich voranbringt. Wie viele Modelle sind denn da in Konkurrenz?
Haben wir hier so eine Singularisierung einer Art und Weise, wie man international so ein Hochschulmodell macht oder ist das tatsächlich noch ein sehr offenes Rennen mit sehr viel unterschiedlichen Eingaben, wie man vormarschieren kann?
Letzteres. Also auch hier haben wir wieder ein Paradoxon derart, dass wir zwar weltweit eine wahnsinnige Zunahme, so wie in der Internationalisierung der Forschung eine wahnsinnige Zunahme der Hochschulbeteiligung, also eine Hochschulexpansion sehen. Das ist ja nicht mehr nur auf Europa und auf reiche Länder beschränkt. Also beispielsweise in China ist ja auch echt in den letzten zehn Jahren die Zahl der Hochschulen hat sich verdreifacht. Also verdreifacht die Zahl der … die haben jedes Jahr einen Ausstoß, Entschuldigung dass ich dieses Wort nehme, Output von zehn Millionen Hochschulabsolventen. Was vor 20 Jahren so außerhalb jeder Vorstellungskraft war.
Zehn Millionen?
Zehn Millionen pro Jahr.
Ja. Das heißt die Hochschulbildung, wenn man so will, ist zu einer Art von globalem Template geworden. Jedes Land, das sich irngwo positionieren will in dieser Wissensgesellschaft mitmischen will, die das Wachstum haben will, das wirtschaftlich avanciert sein will, fördert Hochschulbildung. Und wenn sie selber nicht das Mittel dafür haben, die Ressourcen dafür haben, dann erlauben sie private Initiativen. Und die Menschen, die dort leben, geben viel Geld dafür aus, um irgendwo an einer Hochschulausbildung teilhaftig zu werden. Das sieht man vor allen Dingen in Afrika, das sieht man in Südamerika, wo es einen riesigen Bereich von privater for Profit Hochschulen gibt. Also die meisten amerikanischen berühmten Hochschulen sind privat, aber nicht for Profit, sondern wenn man so will gemeinnützig. Da geht es um schlichtes Geldverdienen von Hochschulkonzernen. Und ihre Kunden, die Studierenden bezahlen sehr sehr viel Geld dafür, dafür die Degrees zu bekommen. Also man sieht weltweit …
Ein Achtel Deutschlands sozusagen?
Die auch extrem angesehen sind?
Nein eben nicht. Aber man sieht eine wahnsinnige trotzdem, weil es nicht sehr viele Alternativen gibt, man sieht eine unglaublich Zunahme von Hochschuleinrichtungen und Studierenden weltweit. Die Zahlen explodieren.
Also Bildung wird ein globaler Markt.
Hochschulbildung ist irgendwo ein globaler Markt. Aber der ist natürlich, wenn Sie so wollen, geschichtet in ganz verschiedene Segmente. Und wenn es darum geht zu sagen, was machen die, die da jetzt schon relativ gut eingeführt und aufgestellt sind, um die ökonomische Sprache zu benutzen, was machen die denn da auf dem Markt? Fördern die jetzt sozusagen one size fits all überall? Dann ist die Antwort, nein. Die machen das jeweils was sie können oder was sie vielleicht für wichtig befinden. Und die Diversität unterhalb dieser extremen Zunahme von Zahlen, die Diversität von Angeboten und Modellen ist sehr sehr hoch. Also die Heterogenität von Providers. Interessanterweise zum Beispiel versuchen die Amerikaner zum Beispiel in Abu Dhabi und in Dubai und in Singapur ein Modell der Hochschulbildung von dem man längst glaubte, das sei jetzt ein bisschen am Ende, zu etablieren.
Nämlich das Liberal Arts College, also die nicht berufsorientierte Hochschulbildung. Die Deutschen haben versucht eher zu sagen, ja deutsche Ingenieurskunst hat einen guten Namen. Wir haben zwar jetzt den Dipl. Ing. nicht mehr, leider leider. Wir haben ja nur noch die Bachelors und die Masters, aber wir können die deutsche Ingenieurskunst mit ihren wunderbaren, wenn man so will, Marktvalue auch nutzen, um das international zu vertreiben und zum einen da Nachfrage zu generieren von guten Leuten, also Studierenden. Aber eben auch möglicherweise potenzielle Kräfte, die wir hier herholen können zu haben und Partner zu generieren auf die lange Sicht.
Vor allem so Paradedisziplinen wie Maschinenbau.
Ja oder Elektrotechnik und so weiter. Und andere machen dann einfach sozusagen die verkaufen irgendwelchen Mist, wofür immer sie Geld bekommen, das sind eben überwiegend die privaten Konsortien, von denen es viele gibt. Börsennotierte mittlerweile in Amerika, in Kanada, in England.
Wenn man jetzt so einen Markt sich entwickeln sieht, dann stellt sich natürlich auch irgendwann die Frage, was ist denn sozusagen auch die wahre Qualität. Es gibt ja jetzt auch schon seit längerem so Ranking-Modelle entsprechender Organisationen, die hier prüfend und vereinheitlichend am Start sind. War ja auch in Deutschland ein Thema mit dem Aufkommen der Exzellenzinitiative der Bundesregierung. Wie kriegt man dieses Problem der Bewertung von Bildungsvermittlung in den Griff, was sind da für Modelle gewählt worden?
Auch das ist ein ganz schwieriges, ein weites Feld, und dass diese Frage überhaupt so eine Relevanz bekommen hat, hat zwei Gründe. Zum einen, weil Hochschulbildung eben sehr sehr viel kostet und immer mehr kostet, haben natürlich jetzt also der Gesetzgeber, die Parlamente, der Staat zunehmend unter Druck gesetzt gefühlt zu sagen, ist es das wert? Also investieren wir dieses Geld richtig? Maggie Thatcher hatte das Value for money genannt, wir wollen wissen was ihr macht und ihr müsst jetzt also berichten, wie eure Leistungen sind und wir wollen auch vergleichen können, damit wir dann möglicherweise nicht so gute, dann doch etwas bestrafen können oder nicht weiter fördern und andere dann belohnen. Also das ist sozusagen der politische, wenn man so will, unter Ressourcenknappheit verfolgte ausgleichende Gerechtigkeitssinn.
Davon ausgehen, dass man immer alles mit Geld bewerten kann.
Dass man machen kann. Und der andere Bereich ist eben dieser internationale Wettbewerb wiederum. Die internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit bzw. auch national, dass man international sieht, dass Wettbewerb, Competition, Competitiveness zu dem, wenn man so will, Leitmotiv wird, wie man bestimmte Prozesse, ob das in Krankenhäusern ist, ob das in Hochschulen ist, ob das in Schulen ist, ob man das vielleicht bei der Polizei noch nicht, aber wie man das dann sozusagen organisiert, weil man davon ausgeht, dass Wettbewerb Leistungssteigerung erlaubt und wenn man so will auch erlaubt, die Guten und die Schlechten zu trennen. Und international heißt das, dass diese internationalen Hochschulrankings, die es noch gar nicht so lange gibt, ich glaube das erste war in der Tat dieses Shanghai Jiaotong Ranking 2003 oder 98, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, also 15 Jahre maximal alt, auf den Markt gekommen.
Hat eine Lawine losgetreten.
2003 war es.
Genau es ging dann weiter mit dem Times Higher Education Supplement Ranking, die waren vorher eigentlich nur national.
Wie heißt das?
Times higher Education Supplement, das Supplement haben sie jetzt glaube ich abgestrichen. Die kommen auch jährlich der zweijährlich. Das sind sozusagen die Globalrankings. Das ist eine ganz neue Gewichtsklasse von Dingen, die jetzt seit dieser Zeit existiert. Und die eigentlich nur Forschungsuniversitäten ins Visier nimmt und anschaut. Warum? Weil das was da erhoben wird an Daten, Publikationen sind oder Reputationen, die sich aus Forschungsleistungen ergeben. Also was für Studierende da sind, wie die Studienleistungen sind, spielt da gar keine Rolle. Das hat was damit zu tun, dass es sehr sehr schwierig ist, das zu erheben und auch international zu vergleichen. Es geht also nur um die Forschungsleistungen mit allen Tricks und Ösen, die es dabei gibt. Also etwa derart, dass in dem Shanghai-Ranking die Zahl der Nobelpreisträger an einer Einrichtung eine Rolle spielt, auch eine recht erhebliche Rolle.
Und etwa hier in Berlin wir das Problem hatten, naja wo gehen denn die vor 1945 jetzt also auch schon tote Nobelpreisträger, wo gehen die denn hin? A Konto freie Universität oder Humboldt? Und in Deutschland hieß es dann, ja wir haben ja diese große Auswahl universitärer Forschungslandschaft und zum Beispiel bei der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft sitzen etliche Nobelpreisträger, die aber nicht jetzt einer Universität zugerechnet werden können, insofern haben wir da in diesem Ranking-Spiel schlechte Karten. Also die internationalen Hochschulrankings sind Forschungsrankings, mit allen Problemen, die es da gibt. Es hat nationale Rankings gegeben. In den USA seit den 70er Jahren, von insbesondere dort Journalen. Also privaten Zeitschriften, den US-News-Worldreport, das erste Collegeranking und dann auch Graduates-Schools-Ranking und Professionals-Schools-Ranking gemacht.
In England dieses Times higher Education Ranking der Universitäten. Aber für den nationalen Markt, wenn man so will, Bildungsmarkt. Und in Deutschland dann dieses von der Zeit, vom CHE Ende der 90er Jahre, damals als noch nicht Ranking genannt, Hochschulkompass oder wie das immer hieß, multidimensionale Ranking, was keine direkten Plätze, 1., 2., 3. hat, sondern versucht, die Leistungen von Hochschulen oder die Angebotsmöglichkeiten zu vergleichen. Um Orientierung für Studienbewerber zu geben.
Also CHE ist Centrum für Hochschulentwicklung. Das ist sozusagen das eigentliche Hochschulranking, wie man es in Deutschland kennt?
Das ist das was sich hier sozusagen verbreitet hat, das ist fachspezifisch. In den anderen internationalen Rankings wird die Einrichtung, eine ganz Universität gerankt. Dieses CHE ist ein studienbezogenes, studienfachbezogenes Ranking und das ist multidimensional. Das heißt es geht um weniger Forschung oder Forschung an Teilreputation auch, aber es geht um Ausstattung, es geht um Studierendenurteile, es gibt also mehrere Dimensionen und es gibt kein klares ordinal skaliertes Rangverhältnis, 1., 2., 3. in dem Fach weiß der Teufel was Physik ist, Heidelberg oder ist Kiel Nummer 1, sondern da werden Gruppen gebildet. Die sind in der oberen Gruppe und die sind in der unteren Gruppe. Das ist also sozusagen ein weiches Ranking. Gleichwohl finden natürlich deutsche Universitäten, Forschungsuniversitäten nochmal Eingang in diese internationalen Rankings.
An deren vorderster Stelle eben das Times higher Education und dieses Shanghai Jiaotong Ranking stehen. Und jedes mal wenn die Neuauflagen dieser Rankings passieren, also dieser global University Rankings, guckt die Bildungspolitik, gucken die Politiker, gucken die Wissenschaftsorganisationen natürlich wie der Hase auf die Schlange und was kommt denn da jetzt raus? Also so wie die Nobelpreisträger erwartet werden von vielen, die Verkündigung, so guckt man dann, haben wir unsere Listenplätze da verändert oder nicht. Und das betrifft nicht nur Deutschland, das betrifft natürlich auch England, das betrifft Frankreich, das betrifft alle möglichen europäischen Länder und China insbesondere, die wie übrigens auch Korea riesigen Ehrgeiz da reinsetzen, in den nächsten zehn Jahren, am besten nächsten fünf Jahren schon einer unter den ersten 20 Universitäten gerankten dort zu haben.
Aber die Exzellenzinitiative jetzt im Besonderen, die ja quasi Exzellenzuniversitäten ausmachen wollte und ja letztlich auch ausgemacht hat in Deutschland, ja im Prinzip nochmal so ihre eigenen Rankingmaßstäbe herangezogen, um diese Bewertung vorzunehmen?
Nein das ist ein anderes Feld. Also wie die jetzt ausgewählt worden sind, das hatte was mit der spezifischen Struktur des deutschen Bildungsförderalismus und der Tradition der Hochschulbildung hier zu tun. Ein Motiv dafür, diese sogenannte Exzellenzinitiative, die jetzt nach ihrer Fortführung Exzellenzstrategie heißt, ist umbenannt worden, also die kommt dann ab übernächsten Jahr, war natürlich die, das war explizit in diesen Verwaltungsvereinbarungen niedergelegt, die internationale Sichtbarkeit der deutschen Universitäten zu stärken, zu verbessern und die Forschungsfähigkeit zu verbessern. Durch Ressourcen, die eingesetzt worden sind, um Forschung zu machen.
Es gibt so eine Art nationales Ranking für internationale?
Nein, nein.
Kann man nicht so sagen?
Nein.
Weil es ja kein Ranking gab. Es gibt jetzt elf Universitäten, die den sogenannten Exzellenzstatus bzw. …
Warum nicht?
Ja gut die waren dann halt in der Exzellenzwolke. Da gab es ja keinen ersten Platz.
Ja in der Cloud. Es gibt kein Ranking. Es gibt natürlich, wenn Sie so wollen, Rankings von Universitäten in Deutschland, von den 85, die es gibt.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht auf so einen Medaillenspiegel oder ein Wettbewerbsreihenfolge hinaus, sondern es wurde ja im Prinzip festgehalten, ihr qualifiziert oder ihr qualifiziert nicht oder noch nicht.
Genau.
Und ob man es nun Ranking nennt oder nicht, hier wird auf jeden Fall eine externe Bewertung vorgenommen, anhand irgendwelcher Kriterien. Und wäre das normale Hochschulranking, so wie ich es bisher verstanden haben vom CHE sagen wir mal sehr noch mit der nationalen Brille drauf geschaut hat, seid ihr gut und wie gut seid ihr im Vergleich? Ist die Exzellenzinitiative ja im Prinzip schon so eine Art Bewertungsübung im Kontext der Internationalisierung der Forschung, also auch was ist sozusagen förderungsfähig, was hat am meisten Entwicklungspotenzial?
Nein nicht ganz. Also die Triebkräfte waren zwei. Erstens der Eindruck, dass in Deutschland die Universitäten in der Forschung ausbluten im Verhältnis zu den außeruniversitären, die es in Deutschland im großen Maße gibt, mit Mitteln zuwächst. Und die universitäre Forschung unter der Überlast der Studierenden und schrumpfenden Budget kracht in allen Fugen und kommt nicht in die Pötte.
Das ist ja eigentlich sagen wir mal der Grundgedanke immer.
Genau. Also mehr Forschung in die Universitäten hineinzupacken und die Forschungsfähigkeit von Universitäten zu ermöglichen und zu verbessern, aber eben gezielt, da wo schon irgendwelchen guten Ansätze sind. Also dass man das jetzt nicht mit der Gießkanne ausbreitet, sondern sagt, gut wo gibt es da was. Und dann hat man aufgerufen einen Wettbewerb in der Tat um Konzepte, um Ideen für Forschungscluster für Graduiertenschulen und für diese Zukunftskonzepte, wie es hieß und die dann durch eine international besetzte Gutachterkommission sozusagen unter den vielen Anträgen dann ausgewählt, wer den Zuschlag bekommt. Also das ging, wenn man so will, es ging darum, Universitäten forschungsfähiger machen zu können durch mehr Geld, was in dieses System fließt, aber eben das Geld so zu verteilen, dass es an die Orte fließt, wo die meisten Chancen bestehen, dass da was rauskommt. Und der zweite Motivpunkt war dann eben, dass man auf diese Weise würde Einrichtungen bekommen können, die in diesem internationalen Ranking-Spiel und in diesem internationalen Sichtbarkeitsspiel ein größeres Gewicht bekommen und mehr mitspielen könnten.
Also haben sich vielleicht die einen oder anderen Politiker erwartet, dass nach 2-3 Jahren Exzellenzinitiative dann einige deutsche Universitäten dann gleich ganz oben landen würden. Was natürlich, wenn man sich die Mittel anguckt, die in dieser Exzellenzinitiative auf dem Spiel gestanden oder jetzt auch weiterhin auf dem Spiel stehen, sollen weiterhin pro Jahr etwa 500 Millionen Euro für alle diese Maßnahmen dann dort auf diese bis zu 15 Universitäten abfließen. Dann ist das euer Ehren lächerlich, wenn man sich anguckt, was für Etats, man muss nicht Amerika gehen, zum Beispiel die ETH Zürich hat, 2,5 Milliarden. Also es ist, und deutsche Hochschulen sind da weit weit hinter zurück. Das ist, wenn man will, nett, das hat viel bewirkt, wenn man so will, in dieser Aufbruchstimmung, internationalen Sichtbarkeit schon etwas getan, aber dass jetzt sozusagen der Ausbruch aus dem Käfig da passierte, oder eine neue Weltspitze kreiert werden könnte, das hätte man glaube ich nie erwarten können.
Kann das sein, dass vielleicht dieses Selbstverständnis, dass die Universität auch wirklich ein, wie soll ich sagen, also wir hatten ja diese Dualität der Forschung und Lehre und natürlich haben auch gerade die Hochschulen in Deutschland unter anderem auch den Auftrag, diese Bildung auch wirklich in die Masse zu bekommen. Ist ja nicht zu vergleichen mit so Eliteuniversitäten, wie wir das jetzt in Oxford und Cambridge hatten. Fällt mir auch gerade ein, wir hatten ja bei Forschergeist auch schon mal ein Gespräch über lehren in Oxford, wo die Ausrichtung einfach eine ganz andere ist. Das heißt hier müssen die Universitäten ja auch erst mal eine ganz andere Grundlast tragen und wollen das ja auch. Andererseits ist aber die Forschung halt nicht unwichtig. Kann das sein, dass das etwas ist, was sich jetzt erst langsam entwickelt? Oder kommen wir da nie hin, dass diese Universitäten sich wirklich primär als Forschungsort verstehen?
Gute Frage. Also ich weiß es nicht, und ich weiß auch nicht, ob es unbedingt gut ist, wenn man sie primär nur als Forschungsort verstehen könnte. Es wäre schon, wenn man so will, ideal. Man hätte dieses beides in irgendeiner Art und Weise zusammen. Ob das mit den derzeit verwaltenden Ressourcen und Auswahlbedingungen für Hochschulen, Finanzierungsbedingungen und Auswahlbedingungen für Studierende möglich ist, das wage ich zu bezweifeln. Also da könnte man noch so viel Geld reinstopfen, das wäre wahrscheinlich sehr sehr schwierig zu machen. Was sie im Moment sehen können ist, dass es auch hier, wenn man so will, eine interne Differenzierung innerhalb der einzelnen Universitäten gibt. Ob die jetzt zur Exzellenzinitiative gehören oder nicht. In einzelne Wissenschaftler oder auch Fachbereiche, die forschungsstärker und andere, die weniger forschungsstark sind oder vielleicht gar keine Forschung machen. Wir haben 85 nominell Forschungsuniversitäten, aber faktisch passiert in sehr unterschiedlichen Maße an diesen Universitäten 85 Forschung.
Und die Leistungen sind auch breit gestreut. Und selbst innerhalb der einzelnen Fächer sind das dann immer noch mal wieder Unterschiede. Und man erlebt, dass es natürlich jetzt aufgrund der, wenn man so will, Gelegenheitsstruktur von einer Forschungsfinanzierung durch Drittmittel der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft, der EU, irgendwelcher privater Stiftungen oder öffentlicher Stiftungen natürlich Professoren gibt, die sich sozusagen bewehrt haben, die forschungsstark sind, wenn man so will, die der Universität den Rücken kehren. Die also das noch als Homebase nehmen, aber viel sich freistellen lassen für ihre Forschungsleistungen, Forschungsfreisemester versuchen zu haben, Vertretungen bezahlen, die ihre Lehrleistungen dann machen, wohingegen sie selber dann irgendwas an ihrer Forschung machen können. Und man hat eben, das ist ein interessanter Effekt dieser Exzellenzinitiative, man hat neue Organisationsformen in den Universitäten. Etwa in Form dieser sogenannten Exzellenzcluster.
Die quer zu den bisherige Strukturen dort liegen. Also Fachbereichen, Departement, Lehrprogrammen. Und wenn man so will, manche würden das so formulieren, Inseln der Seligkeit für Forscher sind, innerhalb dieses ansonsten etwas schwergängigen Universitätsraumes.
Wo etwas aus dem Apparat herausgenommen wird und kürzere Wege hat und mehr Fokus
Kürzere Wege, bessere Ausstattung, mehr Möglichkeiten. Also man behandelt das ungleich.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein positiver Effekt zu spüren?
Je nachdem von welchem Eck man da drauf guckt. Die Gewinner würden sagen, natürlich das ist wunderbar. Ich will die nicht unbedingt als Verlierer nennen, aber es gibt Leute, die eben sagen, nein außerhalb der Wolke das ist ungerecht bzw. die große Stärke des deutschen Hochschulsystems, auch nur bei Universitäten, von Fachhochschulen mal gar nicht zu reden, liegt eben in der Vielfalt und liegt eben auch in der Breite. Und wenn wir Spitze haben wollen, geht in diese Spitze so viel Ressource, so viel Geld, so viel Aufmerksamkeit rein, dass das was man dafür generieren kann vielleicht am Ende des Tages in keinem Verhältnis steht zu dem, was dann an Kollateralschäden in der Fläche angerichtet wird. Also da gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen.
Wie ist denn das in der Schweiz? Wenn die ETH Zürich über 2,5 Milliarden verfügt, wie geht es denn den anderen Universitäten in der Schweiz?
Naja die Schweizer sind sowieso reich.
Gut, aber ich meine jetzt im Verhältnis.
Und es gibt einen Unterschied, diese ETH, eidgenössisch technische Hochschule, das ist die in Zürich und in Lausanne, mit Forschungseinrichtungen, die auch in diesem ETH-Bereich sitzt, werden vom Bund finanziert. Und die anderen Hochschulen der Schweiz, ob das die Uni in Zürich ist oder ob das die Uni in der Stadt Neuchâtel ist oder ob das die Uni in Basel ist, werden von den jeweiligen Kantonen finanziert. Mit einer gewissen Umlagefinanzierung. Das hat ja übrigens auch in Deutschland mal eine Rolle gespielt, als es um diese Exzellenzinitiative ging oder um die Idee, diese Exzellenzinitiative zu machen. Dass man gesagt hat, wir sollten doch vielleicht so was wie Bundesuniversitäten haben. Weil der Bund einfach über mehr Geld verfügen kann und weniger Rücksicht nehmen muss auf ich weiß nicht was, irgendwelche regionalen Ausgleiche hier und dies und das, Koppelgeschäfte.
Ja auch ganz andere Töpfe heranziehen kann als es die Länder können.
Genau und das ist dann aber eben aus, man kann sagen, gutem Grund, weil das nicht gut hier in diese Landschaft gepasst hätte, abgeschafft worden.
Man hätte die ja auch in dem Sinne gar nicht erfinden können, sondern man hätte ja sich im Prinzip eine aussuchen müssen, die man dann einfach rauskauft und dann hier, mal die FU oder …
Ja. Es gibt ja interessanterweise zwei Bundesuniversitäten in Deutschland, nämlich die Bundeswehruniversitäten in Hamburg und in München. Und in Amerika gibt es auch nur drei oder vier Bundesuniversitäten. Die anderen sind, wenn sie nicht privat sind, was die Mehrzahl der Einrichtungen ist, Staatsuniversitäten, also Länderuniversitäten und die Federal Universitys sind auch die Coastguard University, die Airforce Academy und fast hätte ich gesagt Centris, nein also das entsprechende, also die vier Waffengattungen haben sozusagen ihre eigene.
Army, Luftwaffe.
Army, Luftwaffe, Navy also Coastguard, die haben ihre eigenen Hochschulen. Die nicht unbedingt schlecht sind, aber die sozusagen vom Bund finanziert werden. Die anderen Sachen werden alle landesfinanziert oder eben mit Bundesmitteln. Der Bund bezahlt in Amerika ungeheuer viel für die Forschung.
Aber spielt denn bei der Bundeswehruniversität die Forschung für eine Rolle?
Ja doch doch. Die haben ein eingeschränktes Fächerspektrum. Ingenieurwissenschaften, Mediziner, alles mögliche an Pädagogik, Geisteswissenschaft und Sozialwissenschaften. Und die forschen auch. Die sind nicht groß, das sind keine riesigen Einrichtungen. Und ich glaube sie haben auch, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, nehmen auch „zivile Studierende“ auf mittlerweile.
Gibt es denn, wenn wir jetzt nochmal versuchen, versuchen dem Thema der Internationalität zu nähern, jetzt haben wir viel über nationale Programm, nationale Orientierung und überhaupt nationale Wissenschaftspolitik gesprochen, die sich internationalisiert, die sich globalen Herausforderungen gegenübersieht. Zeichnet sich denn auch in irgendeiner Form eine Internationalisierung der Wissenschaftsförderung ab? Gibt es überhaupt Organisationen, die sich auf so einer internationalen, nicht nationalen Ebene mit Wissenschaft auseinandersetzen, die in irgendeiner Form Relevanz hat?
Nicht unbedingt. Also wenn dann kommt dem auch vom Volumen her überhaupt nur nahe die EU bzw. die Kommission mit dem, was früher Rahmenprogramme hieß, und was jetzt Horizon 2020 heißt. Das sind im Horizon 2020 stehen für sieben Jahre 82 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung als Fördermittel. Wobei das nicht nur für Forschung gilt. Sondern das ist, weil die EU ja eigentlich keinen direkten Forschungsforderung oder Bildungsauftrag hatte, aus den römischen Verträgen und dann später der Maastricht-Vertrag. Sondern überwiegend, wenn man so will, für wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und Wirtschaftsförderung steht. Also ob das Zollabbau, Freizügigkeit von Arbeitskräften, Binnenmarkt und so weiter, war die Innovationsförderung da im Vordergrund. Und das waren dann immer Forschungsprojekte, wenn Forschung gefördert wurde, auch unter den Rahmenprogrammen, die sehr anwendungsorientiert war in der Regel.
Und wenn dann nicht in dem Bereich von Ingenieurwissenschaften, aus denen dann unterschiedlichste Herkunftsländer, Gruppen gebildet werden, dann auch im Bereich zum Beispiel sozial oder Gesundheitswissenschaften, die sehr sehr stark an  bestimmten Problemen verpflichtet waren. Das hat sich erst in letzter Zeit etwas geändert, mit der Gründung dieses European Research Councils und der Förderlinie dort, die rein forschungsgetrieben ist. Aber ansonsten gibt es wenig oder um nicht zu sagen gar keine internationalen Organisationen. Die UN hat zwar so was wie zum Beispiel Unesco Chairs, ich weiß gar nicht in welcher Anzahl, die in verschiedenen Plätzen der Welt gefördert werden. Es gibt Stiftungen, die auch international operieren und Forschung fördern oder Forschungsprogramme unterstützen. Dazu zählt also beispielsweise die Volkswagenstiftung hat auch einen internationalen Bereich.
Wobei es da um überwiegend Kooperationen geht von deutschen oder europäischen Wissenschaftlern mit Forschern aus zum Beispiel Israel oder Afrika. Aber all das oder die Melinda Gates Foundation hat auch im großen Umfang Forschungsförderung für nicht nur Amerikaner. Im Vergleich jedoch, also wenn man diese Volumina ansieht, die da zur Verfügung stehen und wer darauf Zugriff hat, ist das verschwindend gering von der Bedeutung her gegenüber den nationalen Förderprogrammen und Finanzierungsformen.
In gewisser Hinsicht habe ich natürlich meine Frage schon falsch aufgestellt, weil selbstverständlich ist natürlich gerade die EU ja eigentlich so das internationalisierteste Wissenschaftsförderprogramm überhaupt. Zumal es ja auch nicht nur auf die EU beschränkt ist, sondern es ja auch Länder gibt, die nicht Teil der EU sind, die daran teilnehmen. Israel zum Beispiel.
Ja. Die Schweiz, Norwegen.
Ich glaube auch Kanada, Schweiz sind in gewisser Hinsicht assoziiert. Und gut, das liegt jetzt natürlich an der supranationalen Struktur Europas und das könnte ja vielleicht auch irgendwann mal ein globaleres Modell werden, vielleicht auch das Programm selbst, dass es eben in zunehmendem Maße das weiterdenkt und sagt, okay jetzt brauchen wir uns gar nicht mehr nur um Förderung der EU beschäftigen. Sondern allein die Tatsache, dass wir hier ein Hub sind für solche Förderung, laden wir in zunehmendem Maße eben auch asiatische, australische, wo auch immer, chinesische Forscher mit ein, an unseren Projekten teilzunehmen. Da wird immer ein möglicherweise auch festgelegter Grundanteil europäischer Nationen daran beteiligt sein, das kann für uns ja nur gut sein.
Ja also so was gibt es im beschränkten Maße. Da gibt es solche, neben diesen Assoziierungsabkommen, wo die Länder dann gewissermaßen gleichberechtigten Zugriff auf die EU-Töpfe haben, diese Forschungsförderungstöpfe, gibt es eben auch eine Reihe von direkten Projektkooperationen mit zum Beispiel Ländern aus dem ehemaligen, das war dann direkt nach 1990, also aus dem ehemaligen postsowietischen Block dort. Oder auch eben aus dem mittleren Osten. Es gibt auch Versuche jetzt, wenn man so will, in Asien dieses Modell des europäischen Hochschulraumes oder des europäischen Forschungsraumes, ERA, European Research Area, stück weit zu imitieren und was ähnliches zu machen dort. Aber da kommen natürlich wer weiß was für nationale Interessen und Eigenheiten und Konkurrenzen ins Spiel, das ist ja sehr schwierig.
Und was die, wenn man so will, die Proliferation des EU-Rahmes oder des EU-Modells betrifft, dürfen Sie eins nicht vergessen, neben der Frage, wen man als Mitglied assoziiert und die dann auch Geld dort bezahlen, gibt es bei vielen nationalen Regierungen und die geben natürlich auch erst mal das Geld an die EU, den mehr oder minder geschriebenen oder ungeschriebenen Grundsatz, dass das Geld des Steuerzahlers nicht außerhalb dieses Raumes geht. Also in Amerika ist das knallhart, die National Science Foundation, die haben wer weiß was für Programme zur Wissenschaftsunterstützung, Capacity Building in Afrika und und und als Entwicklungspolitik oder auch ich weiß nicht was Machtpolitik, aber die National Science Foundation oder auch die National Institutes of Health, die noch viel viel mehr Geld haben als die National Science Foundation, dürfen und können nicht amerikanisches Steuerzahlergeld, public money, in Europa, Afrika, you name it, ausgeben. Das ist also eine, wenn man will, schwer zu überwindende Schwelle.
Aber es gibt doch auch schon Gegenbeispiele. Ich würde mal zwei aufrufen wollen, das CERN, immerhin in Europa mittendrin.
Ja.
Definiert sich ja nicht als EU-Projekt in dem Sinne. Und dann ist natürlich auch noch die internationale Raumfahrt, die ja vielleicht überhaupt das internationalste ist, was es auf diesem Planeten überhaupt gibt. Dort arbeiten Länder mittlerweile zusammen, wo man nicht sich immer gerade so sicher sein kann, ob die sich überhaupt noch lieb haben so, Russland, USA, China kommt in zunehmendem Maße ins Boot. Demnächst sicherlich auch Indien. Also so gesamtpolitisch betrachtet eine Menge Konfliktpotenzial, andererseits läuft es dort so reibungslos, wie eigentlich kaum irgendwo sonst mit Einschränkungen vielleicht, aber immerhin. Ich meine die Raumstation fliegt, things are happening.
Es gibt vier große Projekte, die jetzt so als Big Science, internationale, globale Projekte aufgestellt sind und in der Mehrzahl über Verträge von den jeweiligen Trägern, den Beiträgern auch mit … also das ist ein mitgliedschaftlicher Verein oder was immer die Rechtsform sein mag, in denen dann die dort Zugang haben Wollenden entsprechend Beiträge oder Zuschüsse entrichten müssen. Das betrifft das CERN. Das ist, ich weiß gar nicht wie viele Mitgliedsorganisationen oder Länder die jetzt haben, aber das ist völlig klar, das ist ein riesiger Bereich.
22 Mitgliedsstaaten, heißt es hier.
Und ob die jetzt durch Organisationen oder direkt durch staatliche Einrichtungen vertreten sind weiß ich nicht. Das betrifft die ISS, also International Space Station. Weiß ich nicht, wie viele Mitglieder das hat. Es betrifft auch und vor allem dieses Megaprojekt ITER, diesen Thermoreaktor, der irgendwann mal gebaut werden soll oder bzw. schon gebaut wird. Aber dessen Vollendung sich …
Kernfusionsreaktor.
Kernfusionsreaktor, Jahr um Jahr um Jahr.
Genau 35 Nationen sind es beim ITER.
Also ist jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz zufällig, ITER und BER sind, wenn man die Akronyme sich anguckt, nicht sehr …
Gut aber Flughafen hat man schon mal gesehen, Fusionsreaktor gab es halt noch nicht.
Gut, aber es gibt auch was zum Anschauen und Anfassen, da gibt es wohl auch jede Menge Probleme, weil es eben a) ein neues Ding ist, aber auch in der Ausgestaltung der Verträge mit den jeweiligen Partnerländern war das ein sehr schwieriger Prozess, dass da also zum Beispiel auch Arbeiten, wie sie das oft haben in internationalen Konsortien, dann vergeben werden mussten an Länder, die da irgendwas eingezahlt haben, ohne dass die unbedingt die Kapazität hatten, dieses besondere Device jetzt in der bestmöglichen Art und Weise herzustellen. Da hat man dann die Augen zugedrückt und gesagt, die Schraube kriegen die da in Mazedonien auch noch gedreht, aber ist dann eben oft nicht so gewesen. Und das hat dann extreme Kostensteigerung und Verzögerung zur Folge gehabt. Also das ist CERN, ITER, das ist ISS. Und ein ganz interessantes viel kleineres Projekt, SESAME. SESAME ist ein Beschleuniger, Teilchenbeschleuniger, der in Jordanien aufgebaut worden ist, unter eigentlich UN-Schirmherrschaft.
Mit glaube ich sogar die ursprüngliche Anlage ist sogar aus Deutschland gekommen, ich glaube es war hier vom DESY oder vom BESSY.
BESSY genau. Das Berliner Elektronenspeicherring …
Genau. Beschleuniger, auf den dann eben dort die Wissenschaftler aus unterschiedlichsten Disziplinen, um Messungen zu machen, Materialprüfungen zu machen, zugreifen können. Und interessanterweise ist das ein Beispiel auch, wenn sie so wollen, für, ich hatte vorhin erwähnt, dass ich so ein Projekt mache über Science Diplomacy, das ist etwas für Wissenschaftsdiplomatie oder wie Wissenschaft für internationale Beziehung genutzt werden kann. Da sind nämlich beteiligt Israel, höre und stauen Iran, das Ding liegt in Jordanien, Ägypten und noch 2-3 andere Länder, von denen man auch sagen würde, also die Botschafter würden nicht zusammen in einen Bus steigen. Und die haben dann vielleicht irgendwelche Regeln, wie sie dann dieses Ding da nutzen und dass sie es dann auch so wieder verlassen, wie sie es vorgefunden haben und dann nicht die Schrauben verdrehen. Aber es ist, wenn sie so wollen, eine gemeinsame Zeit, ein gemeinsamer Ort, eine gemeinsame Apparatur, an der die da irgendwas machen können.
Es geht noch weiter, sogar die palästinensischen Autonomiegebiete sind dabei.
Et voila.
Also das ist, und die Türkei.
Jaja.
Super. Okay. Klingt ja schon fast nach einem Friedensprojekt, das kannte ich noch gar nicht.
Naja gut, das ist so ausgeflaggt. Es ist ausgeflaggt als, wenn sie wollen, zivilgesellschaftliche Kooperation. Forschungskooperation zwischen Leuten, die einander nicht …
Ich glaube Wissenschaftler sind dann aber auch wirklich die allerletzten, die dann anfangen, mit einem glühenden Eisen aufeinander loszugehen.
Weiß man nicht. Wenn es darum geht, wer den Preis kriegt dafür, wenn da was entdeckt worden ist.
Aber ich finde, das ist schon ein Wesen der Wissenschaft an sich, ich habe es auch mehrfach besonders im Raumfahrtbereich immer wieder zu hören bekommen, wie auch der Mindset der Leute sich sehr stark entfernt von diesen national, ethnisch, sprachlich geprägten Unterschieden, die immer wieder so viel Thermik erzeugen in der Politik. Da ist einfach in dem Moment, wo man sich so ein bisschen mit diesem Planeten und in gewisser Hinsicht auch mit dem Weltall und dem ganzen Universum beschäftigt, setzt einfach so eine Nichtigkeit dieses Alltags mit ein, das hilft natürlich enorm.
So wie ich das jetzt neulich in irgendeiner Broschüre gelesen habe, der Titel war schon sehr nett, collaborate or die. Als Wissenschaftler, dass du heute auch wirklich international vernetzt sein muss, kollaborieren musst, sonst hat man auch als … das ist gar nicht mal so sehr auf die Nation bezogen, sondern als Wissenschaftler keine besondere Wirkungschance hat.
Ja das bringt uns ja dann zu unserem schönen aktuellen Thema, auf das wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal eingehen müssen. Macht ja ganz so den Eindruck, als ob sich die Briten jetzt mehr auf „die“ eingefahren hätten als auf collaborate. Also wir sprechen vom Brexit, der noch nicht beschlossene, aber zumindest sich abzeichnende Austritt der Briten aus der Europäischen Union. Hat natürlich auch und insbesondere in die Wissenschaftlergemeinde doch extreme Schockwellen ausgelöst. Ich habe selber mit einigen englischen Wissenschaftlern gesprochen, die haben einfach alle nur Augenringe und so einen Hals und sind null froh.
Ja klar, weil zum Community da sehr vernetzt ist mit europäischen Kollegen, aber auch natürlich Amerikanern. Und zum anderen weil die britische Wissenschaft von den EU-Förderprogrammen in hohem Maße profitiert hat. Was daran lag, dass die einfach das Geschäft verstehen, wie man solche Anträge macht, aber auch daran, dass die sehr gut sind. Also die Daten, wie gesagt immer auf die Währung Publikation bezogen, sind da relativ eindeutig. Wenn man sich das mal anschaut, von den weltweiten Publikationen ist die Nummer 1 insgesamt von Publikationen die USA, Nummer 2 China, Nummer 3 schon UK, Nummer 4 Deutschland. Und wenn man jetzt diese, wenn man so will, Publikation …
Auf die Bevölkerungszahl hochrechnet?
Nein, wenn man die jetzt einfach mal rankt, derart wenn man auf die Bevölkerungszahl umrechnet ist das natürlich eine andere, da kommt China …
dann ist Britannien auch vorne, oder nicht?
Wenn man nur guckt, das ist sozusagen ein Qualitätsmerkmal. Ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, dass man Bibliometrie heute nimmt. Man guckt, wie werden Arbeiten zitiert in den anderen Journalen, zählt das aus und kann, wenn man so will, echolotisch dann da verfolgen, wie die sind und hat die Vermutung, dass hochzitierte Arbeiten interessanter oder besser sind. Unter den 17% der Publikationen aus Deutschland zählen in dem jeweiligen Fachgebiet zu den 10% meist zitierten Arbeiten. Also wenn sie Stratosphärenphysik angucken, schauen, was sind da in den letzten 20 Jahren die 10% meist zitierten Arbeiten gewesen, würde Deutschland … die deutschen Arbeiten zur Stratosphärenphysik …
Machen 17% dieser Arbeiten?
Nein von allen Arbeiten, die in Deutschland zur Stratosphärenphysik erschienen sind, sind 17% unter den 10% meist zitierten.
Ach okay so rum.
Die Spitzenreiter da, wenn Sie so wollen, der Qualität- - unter diesen Maßstäben – der Qualitätsproduzenten sind …
Britannien?
Nein Schweiz. Schweiz, Niederlande, dann kommt die USA, dann kommt UK und dann kommt Deutschland. Also das ist ein anderes Ranking oder eine andere Reihenfolge als die, die ich da vorhin genannt hatte, in der Zahl der Gesamtpublikationen. Aber auch da ist es interessant, dass UK, also die sind ja bevölkerungsmäßig nicht so stark aufgestellt wie Deutschland, noch einen deutlichen Abstand zeigen als Deutschland. Das heißt die sind in der Wissenschaft sehr sehr gut und dementsprechend war natürlich auch jetzt wegen Finanzierung, wegen der Sichtbarkeit, wegen der Kooperationsmöglichkeiten die britischen Wissenschaftler und die Wissenschaftsorganisationen und die Universitätspräsidenten, die Vice Chancellors alle not amused über die Aussichten des Brexit, hatten sogar dann, wenn Sie so wollen, sich zum Vorreiter für die no-Brexit Initiative gemacht. Also Zeitungsannoncen geschaltet. Und ob das jetzt auch hier der Stephen Hawking waren und andere Prominente Leute, Royal Society und andere gingen dann voraus.
Und haben gesagt, also da gehen die Lichter aus, wenn wir hier einen Brexit haben. Gut, ob das jetzt denn so kommt, muss man mal abwarten, das hängt letztlich ein bisschen davon ab, was denn die Regierung, und Frau May hat ja da das Blaue vom Himmel versprochen, dass jetzt alles besser, gerechter, breiter würde machen wollen, dann tatsächlich wiederum, es geht um Geld, der Wissenschaft zur Verfügung stehen wird. Und wie die …
Ja ich glaube es gibt schon die Garantie für die nächsten, ich weiß nicht wie viele, Jahre, zumindest jetzt das Level an Funding zu erhalten, was das Geld betrifft. Aber das ist ja nun nicht der einzige Aspekt. Weil was ja jetzt schon passiert ist, da reden wir jetzt gar nicht von der Zukunft, also mit dem Votum sind eigentlich nahezu alle britischen Forscher, die in irgendeiner Form an Horizon 2020 Programm an Neuausschreibungen beteiligt waren, mehr oder weniger hochkant rausgeflogen.
Nein das stimmt nicht, weil jetzt die britische Regierung, also May-Regierung gerade vor 1-2 Monaten nochmal ausdrücklich erklärt hat, dass egal wann und wie hart oder weich Brexit kommt, gemacht wird, die Horizon 2020 Geschichte bis zum Ende der Laufzeit 2020 weiter bedient wird. Also Pakt .... das geht weiter. Und auch alle Projekte, die möglicherweise vorher vor 2020 anlaufen und über 2020 rausgehen in diesem Rahmen, ich weiß nicht, ob das möglich ist, aber jedenfalls, wenn man so will, Folgeprojekte auch abgesichert werden.
Ja aber das ist ja nur eine finanzielle Absicherung.
Richtig.
Das Problem ist ja, dass diese ganzen Initiativen, die sich bei Horizon 2020 bewerben, ist ja ein Konglomerat aus verschiedenen Gruppen und die haben natürlich jetzt kein Interesse mehr daran, eine englische Forschungsbeteiligung zu haben, weil sie das als eine potenzielle Schwächung ihres Programms sehen, weil sie ja davon ausgehen müssen, dass alle Gruppen mit britischer Beteiligung demnächst einfach überhaupt nicht mehr finanziert oder zumindest nicht mehr weiterfinanziert werden und das scheint schon recht endemisch zu sein.
Es hat solche …
Da mag es solche und solche geben, aber diesen Effekt gibt es heute schon.
Es wurde über solche Sachen berichtet. Aber auf der anderen Seite, diese klare Erklärung, Gentlemens Word oder Gentleladys Word.
Ja gut, aber das hilft ja dem Wissenschaftler nicht.
Sie können ja auch jetzt innerhalb der EU kein Projekt vereinbaren, beantragen, was über 2020 bzw. 2020 plus zwei Jahre vielleicht rausgeht. Also alles was jetzt läuft läuft. Alles was jetzt neu beantragt wird, endet ohnehin…
Aber es ist ja eine Angstsituation, in der man halt glaubt, ob das jetzt berechtigt ist oder nicht, dass sozusagen das so ein kleiner Schandfleck ist, wenn man jetzt mit einem britischen Partner in so ein Projekt reingeht. Ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht weiter vertiefen. Man merkt schon, da ist jetzt einfach eine Menge Angst im Spiel.
Ja klar.
Dass sich jetzt hier abwickelt. Und man weiß es jetzt auch nicht. Wir reden jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch ein bisschen ins Blaue hinein. Zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt, wir nehmen das jetzt hier Mitte Oktober 2016 auf, gilt die Aussage, es wird den Austrittsantrag, also dieses Vocation of Article 50 im März 2017 geben. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob man dem Glauben schenken kann oder der jemals kommt.
Wissen wir alle nicht.
Auf jeden Fall ist es eine Phase der Unsicherheit und das war für uns jetzt auch mal interessant zu sehen, okay gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es passiert, was hätte das für Folgen?
Also für die Kontinentaleuropäer vermutlich weniger Folgen, als dass es für die Engländer oder Briten hätte, vorausgesetzt Schottland bleibt dabei. Weil wie gesagt, auf deren Seite dort sehr viel Geld weniger zur Verfügung stehen würde, auf das sie zugreifen können. Und aufgrund ihrer bisherigen Positionierung auch immer gute Chancen hatten, zuzugreifen. Also da würden viele Mittel wegbrechen. Wie sich das jetzt hier für Länder wie Deutschland ausrechnet, die ja auch sozusagen größter Nettozahler waren oder sind, in der Forschungsförderung, ob die dann jetzt sozusagen einsteigen müssen, diese Lücke da aufzufangen oder ob das dann jetzt zu einer Rekalibrierung der jeweiligen Anteile für die Erfolgsquoten und so weiter führt, weiß man nicht. Es könnte ja auch sogar sein, dass, wenn wir das jetzt einfach um die Bereich, den Großbritannien bisher eingebracht hatte, kürzen würde, dann man sagen kann, also für Deutschland beispielsweise. …
Das sind alles Spekulationen jetzt, sind jetzt Ladbrokes … Deutschland die Chancen sich verbessern, etwas von jedenfalls kompetetiven, wettbewerblichen Mitteln abzuwerben, weil die besser einfach da stehen als Griechenland oder Spanien in ihrer Leistungsfähigkeit. Also das muss man abwarten. Wo es möglicherweise schwierig wird ist dann, was die Freizügigkeit der ArbeitnehmerInnen betrifft für Kontinentaleuropäer derart, dass doch eine ganze Reihe von deutschen Wissenschaftlern, die es in hiesigen Landen nicht auf eine Dauerstelle geschafft haben, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, Engpässe, Knappheiten, und es werden ja immer mehr auf kurzfristige Beschäftigungen eigentlich eingestellt und produziert, als Doktoranden, Postdocs etc., dass die es dann nach England vertrieben hat. Also man rechnet damit, dass ungefähr 10.000 deutsche Nationals im britischen Universitäten- und Forschungssystem eine Beschäftigung gefunden haben.
Ob diese Option weiterhin so möglich sein wird weiß ich nicht. Also das wird jedenfalls schwieriger werden. Man kann ja auch heute schon als Deutscher nach USA gehen, aber ist auch nicht trivial. Da muss die dortige Institution, die einen beruft oder einstellen will, sehr viel Geld einmal in die Tasche nehmen, um diese Visagebühren zu bezahlen, das Processing und zum anderen sehr gut begründen, warum kein gebürtiger oder nationalisierter Amerikaner zur Verfügung steht.
Und ähnlich wird es dann ja wahrscheinlich auch in Großbritannien laufen, so wie der aktuelle Trend aussieht.
Ja so ist das.
Und dazu kommt natürlich, dass auch die Atmosphäre natürlich jetzt nicht sonderlich attraktiv ist, weil man ja immer Angst haben muss, also jetzt kann ich hier kein EU-Programm mehr aufsetzen, weil hier läuft halt irgendwie nichts.
Ja.
Genauso könnte es natürlich auch zu einer Landflucht der britischen Wissenschaftler führen oder?
Das könnte sein. Das könnte durchaus sein. Da müssen Sie … ich meine sie haben ja den Vorteil, dass Sie mit englisch überall unterkommen, selbst in Bayern. Andersrum ist es immer etwas schwieriger. Muss man mal gucken. Nur ist die Frage, ob es anderswo eben attraktivere Märkte gibt. Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie viele Deutsche da rüber sind und dass das ein Unequal Exchange ist, in den Deutschland ist von den Arbeitsbedingungen, die es für WissenschaftlerInnen gibt, immer noch einer der attraktiveren Länder oder das attraktivste, wenn man Schweiz ausnimmt, in Europa, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit vielleicht doch oder die Erlebensschwelle doch vielleicht nicht so hoch.
Was macht das attraktiver in Deutschland als in UK?
Einfach dass man hier besser bezahlt wird und bessere Arbeitsbedingungen hat.
Als in Großbritannien?
Als Großbritannien nicht unbedingt, ja teilweise, da ist die Spreizung ja sehr sehr hoch. Also beispielsweise weiß ich von vielen Academics, also Leute, die an Universitäten, Forschungseinrichtungen arbeiten, dass sie sich ein Leben in London, obwohl die Gehälter erst mal ganz gut aussehen, nicht mehr werden erlauben können, sondern zum Teil aus abenteuerlichen Entfernungen da pendeln müssen. Schlicht weil es uneffordable ist. Aber nein was ich meinte ist, dass wenn Sie etwa vergleichen Deutschland und Frankreich, dass hier Wissenschaftler doch sehr sehr viel besser bezahlt werden als in Frankreich. Und von der mediterranen Peripherie mal ganz abgesehen.
Tja also alles nicht so schlimm?
Weiß ich nicht. Nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Also wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt hier Ladbrokes, wir können darauf wetten. Ich befürchte mal, ganz so schrecklich wird es nicht sein. Und es gibt ja den alten Spruch, "fog over the channel - the continent is cut off". Vielleicht ist da auch was dran. Das ist ja jetzt im Grunde genommen was Theresa May versucht zu propagieren, dass es eine blühende Zukunft ohne die EU geben wird. Und wenn Sie sich angucken, wie jetzt also beispielsweise nicht die City, aber viele Unternehmerverbände dort reagieren oder auch der Immobilienmarkt in London, dann scheint die das ein Stück weit zu kaufen. Also da muss man mal gucken.
Na gut, also das Pfund scheint hier der Logik noch nicht so ganz folgen zu können. Da sind wir so kurz vor einem historischen Tiefststand. Es sind natürlich immer nur Momentaufnahmen, das kann nächste Woche schon wieder alles anders sein. Ich weiß nicht, in gewisser Hinsicht ist das natürlich auch irgendwie ein sehr unwissenschaftlicher Move. Jetzt hatten wir gerade so schön diese Internationalisierung und überhaupt so diesen globalen Geist der Kooperation, collaborate oder die, beschworen und sehen jetzt ein Land, was halt ganz offensichtlich ja auch unter so populistischem Druck sich ohne groß über die Konsequenzen Gedanken zu machen, jetzt auf einmal auf so eine politische Schiene gesetzt wird, die von Leuten moderiert wird, die selber dagegen waren. Das ist ja nunmal bei Theresa May so.
Hat sich nicht erklärt.
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt was sie wie gemeint hat, weiß man jetzt auch nicht. Jetzt läuft es halt darauf hinaus, am Ende scheint es doch immer noch mehr eine Krise der konservativen Partei zu sein. Die jetzt alle ausbaden müssen. Schön ist das auf jeden Fall nicht. Aber es ist ja an sich ein Run in so einen …
Existentialistisch
Ja existentialistisch wollte ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber in so eine Isolation hinein. Man träumt so ein bisschen davon, dass Hongkong Europas zu werden. Und ich frage mich, ob das halt überhaupt, wenn man sich diese ganzen Trends, die wir jetzt so ausführlich eingangs besprochen haben, anschaut, ob das überhaupt noch zusammenpasst. Ob überhaupt ein Land, was sich so einigelt und sich aus schon erarbeiteten europäischen und internationalen Kontexten versucht herauszulösen, ob das überhaupt das Mindset ist, an dem sich die Wissenschaft selbst dann auch so weiterentwickeln kann, wie sie es sonst eigentlich getan hätte.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also als genetisch Anglophiler, meine Großmutter war Engländerin, dort kurz studiert habender, würde ich sagen, dass diese Handelsnation immer noch ein gewisser starker Pragmatismus eigen war und dass sie das irgendwie auch werden so oder so schaufeln können, ohne dass da jetzt die Glaubenskriege ausbrechen. Was wir jetzt allerdings erleben ist in der Tat eine Konsequenz oder eine Erscheinungsform dessen, was mal, ich glaube Ernst Bloch war es, genannt hatte, die Gleichzeitigkeit des Ungleichzeitigen. Dass es also viele Menschen gibt dort, die sich von der, in England das kann man ja nur ganz deutlich sehen, wenn man die Wahlergebnisse nach Distrikten und Altersgruppen und Status sich differenziert anschaut, die sich abgehangen fühlen von dieser Entwicklung und die sagen, genug ist genug. Also "is over". Und wir wollen mit dieser EU nichts zu tun haben. Nun ist das eine schlechte Kröte, die man da schlucken muss.
Aber wie das sich dann alles auswirkt und ob dann diese Idee als sozusagen Hongkong vor dem Kontinent der "cut off" ist dann zu blühen, aufgeht oder nicht, hängt ja nicht zuletzt auch davon ab, wie sich diese Nationalismen, wie sich diese Isolationismen, wie sich diese Retrogeschichte innerhalb der EU selber auch nochmal entwickelt. Der verbleibenden 27 Mitglieder. Und da kann man ja auch nicht die Garantie dafür geben, dass jetzt gerade auch nach dem Brexit sozusagen ein straffendes... und jetzt vorwärts immer, rückwärts nimmer, passieren würde. Oder dass das gut ausgeht. Also da muss man ja auch schon eine gehörige Portion Optimismus, glühenden Optimismus haben, um zu glauben, dass das jetzt alles so smoothly weitergeht.
Tja kann denn die Wissenschaft da überhaupt irgendwas zu beitragen?
Ich vermute mal nicht, nein. Das ist ja, wie Sie das sehen, das ist Volksdemokratie. Das ist ein Begriff, der ja aus der sozialistischen Hälfte dieses Kontinentes stammte oder bzw. Mediendemokratie und wie unberechenbar das ist und wie unlenkbar, kann man ja beispielsweise auch wunderbar jetzt im amerikanischen Präsidentschaftswahlkampf sehen. Und ja also da verschlägt es einem ja auch den Atem, den wissenschaftlichen zumal.
Das tut es. Und vielleicht für den Ausklang der Sendung nochmal eine Interessante Metafrage, weil wir ja auch mit dem WZB angefangen haben und auch so im Prinzip der soziologische Blick da ist. Jetzt haben wir so viel über Politik und wirtschaftliche Faktoren gesprochen. Welches Verhältnis hat Wissenschaft zur Gesellschaft derzeit? Und lässt sich vielleicht irgendein Trend oder zumindest ein Fünkchen Hoffnung ablenken, dass diese Komponenten stärker zusammenkommen? Dass sozusagen die Erkenntnisse der wissenschaftlichen Forschung auch das Weltbild, was ja dort eigentlich gewonnen wird, was teilweise, wenn man sich halt jetzt Religion und auch so die interethnischen Debatten anschaut, so weit entfernt zu sein scheint. Teilweise Jahrzehnte, teilweise Jahrhunderte, wenn nicht gar Jahrtausende.
Ist es irgendwie zu fühlen oder ist es überhaupt nur denkbar, dass diese Wissenschaft wieder einen Einfluss auf diese Gesellschaft bekommen kann? Und in der Lage ist, da vielleicht auch einen Diskurs, wenn nicht zu diktieren, doch zumindest so stark zu beeinflussen, dass man da so nicht mehr so einen großen Dissens hat?
Also ich wäre da sehr skeptisch. Einerseits ist die Wissenschaft natürlich einflussreicher denn je, weil wie gesagt wir in einer Wissensgesellschaft leben, von Erfindungen ich weiß nicht was, nicht nur wissenschaftlich, aber wissenschaftlich eingeleitet und von wissenschaftlich qualifiziertem Personal, vorgenommene Erneuerungen und Produkte und Prozesse für das Wohlergehen dieser Gesellschaft in vielen Bereichen immer wichtiger werden und essentiell sind. Und zugleich ist aber der Führungsanspruch oder der Aufklärungsanspruch, den Sozialwissenschaften lange zeit vor sich hergetragen haben und an ihre Brust geheftet haben, doch sehr stark verblasst. Das ist allerdings eine Sache, die schon länger zurückliegt. Ich erinnere mich an die 80/90er Jahre, als es nochmal eine Initiative geben sollte in Frankfurt war es da, ein denkwürdiger Kongress, Zukunft der Aufklärung, nochmal also die, wenn Sie so wollen, aufgeklärte linksliberale Öffentlichkeit im Nachhall Frankfurter Schule.
Wir wissen sozusagen die Weltrezepte, wir wissen es besser, wir klären euch mal auf, was wir machen sollen können, zusammenzurufen. Und das ist also auch sozusagen abgestürzt und verhallt. Und wir haben zugleich eben doch von Wissenschaft sehr sehr viele, die dann sozusagen als Spindoctors in Thinktanks und ich weiß nicht was arbeiten. Oder wissenschaftliche Expertisen, Gutachten jeder Menge publizieren für Ministerien, für Unternehmen und und und. Aber so eine, sagen wir mal, auch eine, das erleben Sie nicht nur in Deutschland, in Frankreich ähnlich, Amerika etwas anders, eine abnehmende Attraktivität, so was wie des intellektuellen Diskurses oder einer wissenschaftliche munitionierten öffentlichen Debatte, einer öffentlichen Deliberation über das Gemeinwesen und über Politik. Wir haben unendliche Mengen an Daten über alles mögliche, die von der Wissenschaft produziert werden und die auch zum Teil abgerufen werden.
Aber in der Öffentlichkeit, in der öffentlichen sozusagen auch Achtung, Anerkennung, von dem Echo ganz zu schweigen, den Wissenschaftlern gegenüber gebracht wird, haben wir glaube ich doch einen Niedergang zu verzeichnen. Und ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist bin ich auch wiederum agnostisch. Also man kann ja sagen, was da manchmal sozusagen zusammen fabuliert worden ist, in den Zeiten, als es noch die Intellektuellen Hohepriester gab oder die wissenschaftlichen Meisterdenker, war ja nun auch bei Lichte besehen mit Erfahrung und Rückblick von 20-40 Jahren zum Teil zum Grauen bekommen. Aber es ist ein Fakt, dass die Wissenschaft nicht ohnmächtiger geworden ist, aber und er Öffentlichkeit in vielen Bereichen weniger präsent ist, in anderen Bereichen aber umso wirkmächtiger geworden ist. Auch da Vielfalt.
Ja. Gut ich meine vielleicht ist das auch wieder nur so eine Sinuswelle, deren Frequenz man noch nicht so genau bestimmen kann.
... wo der Scheitelpunkt liegt...
Wenn ich so überlege, gerade so zum Ende des Krieges hin in den 50er Jahren war ja Wissenschaft für eine Zeit lang im Prinzip ja die Verkörperung des Zukunftstraumes.
Ja Aufklärung. Rationalität.
Aber eben auch so als Mittel des Fortschritts, Energie, Reise zum Mond, all das hat sozusagen die Träume erfüllt und das hat im Prinzip auch alles geleitet. An dem Einfluss auf die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung hat es sich eigentlich ja nur noch vervielfacht, nur ist das nicht so zu spüren. Es ist nicht so greifbar, es ist nicht so präsent. Ich will gar nicht so viel jetzt über die Zukunft orakeln, aber ich wundere mich halt schon, ob wir jetzt hier vielleicht auch erst mal so ein bisschen dieses Nationale in gewisser Hinsicht überschritten haben müssen und dass so eine Grundeinstellung auch wieder eine Chance hat auf so einen zweiten Frühling. Man will zum Mars reisen, man hat in zunehmendem Maße diese internationale Kooperation nicht nur in der Wissenschaft, sondern auch in der Wirtschaft, auch im Tourismus.
Also so sehr es Gegentendenzen gibt, ist ja eine Globalisierung dieses Planetens und diese Verkürzung der Abstände, die ja auch viele dieser Kräfte jetzt freisetzt, die sich versuchen dagegen zu, gegen diese Änderung entgegenzustrecken, findet es ja nichts desto trotz statt. Wir haben eine Globalisierung der Sprache, wir haben durch das Internet eine Globalisierung der Kommunikation. Es wird eine ganz neue Nähe dargestellt und oft ist es ja so, dass solche Prozesse teilweise 10-20-30 Jahre irgendwie im Untergrund selbst von einer medialen Öffentlichkeit kaum wahrgenommen wird, bis sie sich dann durch irgendein Ereignis auf einmal so Bahn bricht und weit ist. Kann man doch schon ein bisschen Hoffnung schürfen oder?
Ja klar, also die Internationalisierung ist, wenn man so will, nicht hufhaltbar, auch nicht zurückzudrehen. Die Internationalisierung der Wirtschaft ist ja mit den Händen zu greifen, nicht nur bei multinationalen Konzernen, sondern auch wenn man sich anguckt, gerade in Deutschland Exportweltmeister, wie viele auch kleinere Unternehmen, Beratungsunternehmen internationale Kontakte haben, internationale mobiles Personal, Leute von dort heuern, Leute dahin schicken. Also das ist ja auch, wenn man so will, alltagswirklich. Immer mehr Menschen reisen immer weiter. Haben viel mehr von der Welt gesehen. Sind in Unternehmen tätig, die sie jetzt mal nach Hongkong oder mal nach Kapstadt schickt. Also das ist ja unbestreitbar und das ist auch alles nicht zurück zu holen. Und die Erfahrungen verändern sich. Zugleich bleibt eine Spaltung. Es gibt immer mehr, die zurückgeblieben sind und die zurückbleiben.
Und so wie es jetzt Regionen gibt, in denen man das sehen kann und das ist nicht nur der ehemalige Osten in manchen Bereichen, in denen der wirtschaftliche Aufschwung oder die Anschlussfähigkeit noch nicht wieder da ist, sondern zunehmend mehr auch sozusagen semiländliche Regionen in Westdeutschland, um nur mal das zu nehmen oder in Frankreich.
Oder in Großbritannien.
Oder in Großbritannien. Und wo dort eben die Menschen das Gefühl haben, oh my god, dass irgendwo jetzt die Notbremse gezogen wird, ich will dieses Spiel nicht mehr mitmachen. Und das heißt also die …
Die Bedrohung ist das andere, das was ich nicht kenne.
Ja und diese Kollateralschäden, die damit kommen bzw. die Kosten, die damit verbunden sind, weil eben "the left behinds" auch da sind und die Rechnung aufmachen, werden auch sehr sehr groß und schwierig. Und wie sich das mal so oder mal so auswirkt, kann man schwer sagen. Man kann nicht sagen, ihr seid einfach die Dummen, ihr werde disenfranchised, ihr dürft nicht mehr abstimmen. Ja Pech gehabt.
Das wird nicht helfen
Es ist schwierig, wie wir damit umgehen, das macht es extrem unberechenbar. Und wenn man in der Tat jetzt mal zurückblickt so vor 50 Jahren, diese Planungseuphorie, wir leben in einer Gesellschaft, die sich also durchgestalten lässt, und wo alle ….
Fliegende Autos.
Fliegende Autos. Die tollste Utopie, die ich in einer Jungenzeitschrift, die es jährlich gab, das neue Universum, von 1961 gelesen habe, war den ganzen Autoverkehr in Paris unter die Oberfläche zu legen und die Beleuchtung dieses subterranen Areals, damit die Stadt als Museum erhalten werden kann, durch eine Vielzahl von Atomkraftwerken unter der Erde auch zu sichern. Also solche Geschichten, wo die Zukunft unendlich war, gab es ja jede Menge und daran fehlt es uns ja heute doch sehr stark. Und wir sind ja froh, wenn wir irgendwie so halbwegs beieinander bleiben. Insofern gilt das alte von mir sehr geschätzte Wort von Karl Valentin, diesem Münchner Kabarettisten aus den 20er Jahren, das war vielleicht auch seine Partnerin Lise Karstadt immer mehr, früher war auch die Zukunft besser.
Ja hat stark nachgelassen. Ulrich Streiterer vielen Dank für die Ausführungen…
Nichts zu danken.
… zur Internationalisierung der Forschung.
Und also ein bisschen optimistisch darf man doch sein. Optimismus ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht.
Trotz Brexit.
Genau.
Ja vielen Dank.
Nichts zu danken.
Und vielen Dank natürlich auch allen wieder hier, die zugehört haben bei Forschergeist. Wir werden die Schlagzahl demnächst sogar noch ein wenig erhöhen. Auf jeden Fall geht es weiter und bis dahin sage ich tschüss bis bald.